Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten.
Die Bundesregierung will uns jetzt zehn Megabit als garantiertes Netz äh anbieten. Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich dazu noch sagen soll.
Das jetzt nur wieder so ein klassischer LMP-Introvitz, oder?
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer 43 vom 17. Mai 222 und äh hast du Internet? Restinterview. Presse.
Restinternet Rest Internet.
Bisschen Resteversorgung, was so was in Deutschland so macht, ne. Die nehmen einfach das das Netz, was bei den anderen Ländern übrig geblieben ist und das großflächig verteilt, so als Almosen.
Diese Mindestregelung ja zehn mBit down eins Komma sieben ab, ja,
stellt die Breitbandszene vorher Herausforderungen, eine mögliche Lösung, Satelliteninterne. So, also wir schießen tausende Satelliten ins All.
Ins All.
Bevor wir irgendwie eine Schippe nehmen und ein bisschen Glasfaser in Deutschland verlegen. Soweit sind wir. Das ist Hightech. Das ist eine Hightech-Nation. So läuft das nämlich.
Wo wollen Sie sich fucking Satelliten nennen? Wo wollen Sie Raketen hernehmen, um die Satelliten hochzuschießen? Kriegen Sie's doch noch nicht mal hin, mehr als fünf Starts da irgendwie in Europa zu machen pro Jahr. Es ist doch einfach alles vorbei.
Es ist äh es ist also das ist also wenn ich denke.
Die holen einfach den Ilon rein und sagen, mach, mach du mal. Wir kriegen das nicht hin.
Es ist eine Katastrophe. Es ist eine mittelschwere Katastrophe. Es ist es ist eine sehr schwere Katastrophe.
Das ist eine sehr schwierig.
Ich finde es, es ist so lächerlich irgendwie so. Ja hm äh bevor wir in diesem Land irgendwie eine Infrastruktur brauchen, können wir nicht vielleicht lieber äh den Weltraum versuchen zu benutzen. Der ist noch nicht ganz so totreguliert.
Eins Komma sieben Megabit, ich meine, der denkt sich so was aus. Was was.
Clemens, Clemens würde sagen, det kannst du auch über nassen Schnürsenkel schieben.
Ja. Genau. Man sollte nasse Schnürsenkel verteilen in Deutschland.
Spende nasse Schnüs.
Oh Gott. So, heute ist ein besonderer Tag, Linus.
So, heute ist ein besonderer Tag. Weil ich recht hatte.
Nein? Auch.
Ja aber das ist kein Besonderer.
Doch. Gesagt ist, gesagt.
Nee, ich weiß gar nicht, wann haben wir das letzte Mal in der Metaebene so in real eine Sendung aufgenommen?
Ich würde sagen, da gab's doch kein Corona. Ich ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass wir seit Corona hier eine Sendung hatten. Und ich habe ich musste ja heute ähm durch Prenzlauer Berg und und ja man fragt sich eigentlich immer so, warum Leute Prenzlauer Berg so hassen,
Bis man mal hin muss.
Und dann, was passiert dann?
Dann versteht man das alles.
Gestern Abend war Scheiße, da ist hier irgendwie so eine so eine Truppe Schwabler durch die Straße gezogen. Die haben ja irgendwie äh in diesem Block.
Haben Demeter äh Brötchen Brötchen verkauft oder was.
Die sind so mit so Herzchen Gesten irgendwie durch die Straßen gelaufen und haben da irgendwie äh ihr Putinverständnis äh durch die Straße getragen, weil sie hier irgendwie äh wohl den Lauterbach einkringeln wollten, der ja hier irgendwie wohnt.
Das ist alles total furchtbar und schlimm und grauenhaft. Was ist aus diesem.
Geworden.
Ja, ich meine, die haben sich früher immer schon nicht gegen gegen Masern geimpft irgendwie. Kitzelwitz irgendwie so? Hey, wir können uns auch im Pressauer Berg treffen. Ich bin geimpft. Na ja.
Aber äh das hat ja auch einen Grund, warum wir äh uns hier eingefunden haben, denn wir haben Gäste,
Was für welche? Wir begrüßen den Viktor und Kalesi. Hallo,
Herzlich willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik und äh ja wollen wir erstmal vorstellen?
Viktor kennen doch alle schon. Ach so. Äh LNP, weiß nicht mehr genau, welche Folge, Camp zwanzig neun1, Systemabsturz.
Erzähl mir doch mal, wo du recht hattest. Wo hast du recht?
Ich hätte, das sprengt jetzt den Rahmen der Sendung, wo ich überall recht hatte,
Wird Twitter nicht kaufen. Er hat ein Haar in der Suppe gefunden,
Ich habe es gesagt und er hat es äh getan.
Ja, es ist on hold. Das Lustige ist, sowas gibt es äh finanztechnisch gar nicht.
Er hat es na ja na klar, wenn er sagt, das Produkt entspricht nicht den äh Versprechungen da gibt's doch mehr als fünf Prozent äh.
Du meinst Twitter ist abgelaufen oder was?
Wenn du mehr als 5 Prozent Fake-Accounts hast, ich fand das schon sehr klug, von ihm irgendwie deren Bluff äh irgendwie halt einfach zu callen. Also mehr als 5 Prozent Fake-Accounts ist äh
jetzt äh vorsichtig geschätzt dann doch ähm potenziell könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es eventuell sein könnte,
damit hat er ja dann kann er ja sagen, das Produkt entspricht nicht den Versprechungen ähm von Jack Dorsey.
Stand so im Verkaufskatalog?
Wird sicherlich irgendwo mal behauptet und dann.
Jetzt mit noch mehr Bots.
Tim, also ich meine, wenn du wenn du wenn du so viel Geld ausgibst, ne, dann dann musst du dich ja auch darauf verlassen, dass das Produkt den äh Beschreibung entspricht.
Na ja, also vielleicht äh war's ihm dann doch zu peinlich, äh zugeben zu müssen, dass er seine ganze äh sein Recht auf Meinungsäußerung ausgerechnet mit dem Geld aus Saudi-Arabien finanzieren wollte, ist äh.
Das fand ich sehr schön, Deckel ist ein sehr schön äh Einlassung von Trevor Noah. Äh der so sagte, tja, also der Elon Musk ist der reichste Mensch der Erde, aber sein Vermögen kann man nicht besteuern, weil das ja alles in Aktien ist.
Und warum kann man das nicht besteuern, weil er nix davon kaufen kann? Jetzt geht er aber damit hin und kauft sich Twitter,
stellt sich natürlich schon die Frage so, ach so, du kannst ja auch von nichts kaufen, wir können's nicht besteuern, aber du kannst dir davon Twitter für über 40 Milliarden US-Dollar kaufen,
Da stimmt ja irgendwas nicht.
Ich glaube, es ging darum, dass er das sozusagen als Sicherheit äh angibt, dass es sozusagen einen Wert äh darstellt, dass er diese Aktien ja hat. Ja es ist alles, es macht alles überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Auf jeden Fall ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob's nicht doch noch dazu kommt, aber äh er hat jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal einen Schwanz eingezogen,
vielleicht auch ganz gut so.
Er hat der hat
ich würde tatsächlich sagen, wir hatten das strategische Haar in der Suppe jetzt äh gezeigt und er wird also er ist natürlich jetzt auch gezwungen, die Testeraktien sind äh relativ stark gefallen
irgendwie in letzter Zeit ähm was es ihm natürlich auch schwieriger macht, die will er ja zur Sicherheit anbieten für die Kredite, um Kriter zu kaufen. Das heißt, jetzt muss er noch mehr von Tesla abgeben zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt,
und ähm ich meine, der Mann wäre nicht in diese Position gekommen, wenn er nicht gut verhandeln könnte. Und äh ich also ich denke, er wird versuchen,
nachzuverhandeln oder das ganze Ding jetzt daran platzen zu lassen.
Gucken wir mal, ob du am Ende recht behältst.
So, aber jetzt mal zu euch äh beiden. Ja, ihr wart ähm ich weiß nicht, also Viktor, du warst schon mal du warst schon mal so in der Sendung, aber nur ähm was heißt nur? Du warst ähm aufm Camp,
auf der Bühne mit uns zusammen.
Nur in einer Livesendung, dass nachher noch Musik gemacht, aber sonst eigentlich nicht. Sonst also sonst eigentlich.
Sonst eigentlich nix, genau, ja. Ich muss also grad mal meine Erinnerung.
Ich hatte Hunger, es war kein optimaler Tag. Das weiß ich noch.
Aber du hast schön gesungen. Genau, weil ähm,
Du bist ja bekannt durch dein Engagement in der Band äh System äh Absturz in für dein Engagement bei digitale äh Freiheit und mittlerweile auch im CCC aktiv.
Kann man das so zusammenfassen.
Das äh Kapitel mit digitaler Freiheit ist jetzt zu Ende gegangen. Mhm. Da habe ich irgendwann gemerkt, da musste ich dann mal sagen, okay,
So wenn man das nach vier Jahren irgendwie die Opas, die Papas müssen auch mal gehen irgendwann. Äh nö, sonst kann man das alles so sagen.
Nach vier Jahren.
Ganz schreckliche.
Sicher, dass wir den in.
Ratskehr.
Kümmern wir uns um die CC.
Mit echten Kindern.
Diese Millenials, die haben einfach diese Zeiträume noch nicht so im Blick. So und äh auch herzlich willkommen zu ähm dir, Kalesi,
Du bist auch schon einer größeren äh Öffentlichkeit bekannt geworden, weil du die C3 News Show moderiert hast,
Alleine, aber wie groß war das Team eigentlich?
Ja, das ist glaube ich äh fluktuiert so ein bisschen. Es gibt ein Kernteam und dann kommen da mal Leute dazu oder auch nicht,
Genau, ich habe aber zum Beispiel dieses 40 Jahre CC Geburtstagsvideo alleine moderiert und die Menschen, die den Videoschnitt bei uns machen, haben es netterweise zusammengeschnitten.
Mhm. Und du bist aber auch ganz wild äh aktiv unter anderem bei der AG äh Kritis.
Es gibt Frauen in der AGitis, das glaubt uns ja immer keiner, aber es ist so. Ja, doch, das werde ich häufiger gefragt, ob's dann noch andere Frauen gibt, aber wir sind relativ viele Frauen.
Okay. Ich habe das nie in Zweifel gezogen und ähm aber auch äh im CCC unterwegs,
Und warum haben wir euch eingeladen? Wir haben euch eingeladen, weil ihr äh grade sehr viel politischende Aktivität entfaltet rund um unser Dauerthema. Die Chatkontrolle. Ja, Leute, wir werden heute nochmal über die Chatkontrolle reden.
Und ähm da dachten wir uns, holen wir euch doch mal in die Sendung.
Die jungen Leute rein, ne, die nach vier Jahren locken.
Das ist jetzt auch fast schon vier Jahre her, dass wir da saßen. Drei, oder?
Also dann, warum haben wir dich nochmal eingeladen?
Nächstes Mal komme ich alleine.
Dicker auch.
Nächstes Mal erst wenn das neue Album draußen ist.
Muss man aber auch noch erwähnen, ne? Systemabsturz war jetzt letztes Wochenende mit Egotronic on Tour, Vorband. Also Egotronic war eure Egotronic war eure Nachband.
Ja, genau, genau. Also wir haben zwei Konzerte mit Egotronic als Nachband.
So noch.
In Bonn und Oberhausen gespielt.
Wunderbar. Ja, Egotronic ist als Nachband gar keine schlechte Wahl. Also irgendjemand muss die Leute auch nachher noch mal runterrocken, ne?
Rausschmeißer nee finde ich super.
Ja und? Was bevor wir jetzt äh ich würde sagen, bevor wir jetzt hier in die harten Themen äh einsteigen, muss man glaube ich nochmal ähm wolltest du noch einen Dank loswerden, oder?
Genau und zwar bei Manu vom C 3 Sticker Operation Center.
Da haben wir hier ein wunderschönes Paket mit Stickern und Tim hat's ja gerade schon gesagt, es ist jetzt das erste Mal seit langer Zeit, dass wir hier wieder gemeinsam in der Metaebene sind und da haben wir gemeinsam
Pakete geöffnet und erfreuen uns gerade einen wunderschönen Aufklebern.
Und äh das äh C drei Sticker Operation Center hat ja insbesondere auch in den dunklen Jahren ähm mit der Pandemie
beeinträchtigten Chaosveranstaltungen im Internet, die äh Religion des Stickertausches aufrechterhalten und äh wenn man da mal so eine schöne Sticker
Sammlungen vor sich hat, dann äh weiß man auch, wie wichtig das ist. Deswegen, vielen herzlichen Dank.
Systemabsturz Sticker, oh ja gibt's. Sehe gerade einen.
Also sie existieren, sie sind nicht in dieser Kiste drin, aber.
Wo siehst du einen?
Aus dem Laptop. Wo sie hingehören.
Digga? Muss ich hier fragen.
Du hast nie gefragt? Muss ich hier fragen? Anscheinend schon.
Äh Statuscourt äh vier dreißig. Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich hier mal äh Viktor ein bisschen äh prüfen, aber Tim, herzlichen Glückwunsch übrigens zu bestandenen Motorradführerscheinprüfung.
Dankeschön. Besten Hund natürlich, ne.
Da gibt's keine Noten. Da gibt's sogar einen Führerschein oder nicht.
Die tatsächlich steht auf dem.
Deinem Führerschein nochmal so ein Flyer, haben die denen noch so ein kleines Pärchen draufgemacht. So ein Einhorn,
so ein Einhornstempel.
Nee, äh das äh leider nicht, aber ähm es gibt tatsächlich, man kriegt tatsächlich ein Prüfprotokoll,
Da steht aber nur, äh dass ich alles richtig durchgeführt habe und dann äh gibt's auf der letzten Seite noch äh ihre Prüfungsleistungen im Detail. Sagt sie so, wow.
Prüfungsfahrt, Fahraufgaben. Bei der Ausführung der Fahraufgaben wurden keine überdurchschnittlichen Leistungen und Fehler dokumentiert.
Keine überdurchschnittlichen Leistungen.
Drei.
Was ich ein bisschen enttäuschend fand, aber okay. Ich freue mich, was ich dafür hätte tun können.
Leistung,
hat deine Halle keinen Sportauspuff oder was.
Vielleicht also so wie die Polizei das macht und die sind doch immer so Pyramiden irgendwie mit mehreren Leuten auf Motorrädern. Vielleicht.
Eine überdurchschnittliche Leistung. Also also das heißt, du hast einen tot gefahren.
Ich ich habe einfach nur nix falsch gemacht. Das war eigentlich auch mein Fokus, um ehrlich zu sein,
Ja, man man kann ja auch Glück haben, ja. Also zum Beispiel, wo ich total drauf ähm vorbereitet war, ist, dass mir ein Bus entgegenkommt und an einer anderen Haltestelle hält und die Warnblinkanlage anmacht. Weißt du, was man dann tun muss?
Warten. Also beim Auto warten.
Schnell noch links überholen.
Wenn du das ankreuzt, ist alles vorbei. Nee, du musst maximal Schrittgeschwindigkeit dran vorbeifahren. Das hätte ich gerne gemacht,
dann hätte ich, dann hätte ich ein Bienchen bekommen. Das hätte dann hier äh.
Überdurchschnittliche Leistung.
Definitiv. Ja das ist eine überdurchschnittliche Leistung gewesen, aber äh egal. Aber da fragt ja Gott sei Dank auch keiner danach. Und jetzt kann ich ähm die Gegend unsicher machen.
Also es sind keine überdurchschnittlichen Leistungen. Was war wie war denn deine Fahrprüfung? Wo bist du denn lang gefahren?
Wie genau möchtest du's jetzt wissen? Nordendip von Berlin. Man fährt halt so über die äh über die Länder und die Dörfer und ähm.
Gut, dass er jetzt auch keine überdurchschnittliche Leistung.
Nee, aber der Fahrprüfer hat auch keine überdurchschnittliche Leistung gebracht, weil.
Liegt immer am Prüfer, der Prüfer war ein Arschloch, ne?
Der Prüfer äh hatte keine Information über die aktuelle Baustellenlage und so muss ich dann noch nicht mal auf die Autobahn fahren, weil die Autobahnzufahrt war halt gesperrt.
Okay, das ist auch geil. Dann konntest du deinem Gefährt ja auch keine überdurchschnittlichen Leistungen abverlang.
So sieht's aus. Ich wurde eigentlich um den Ruhm gebracht. Der sich schön in meinem Dekra-Prüfprotokoll hätte niederschlagen.
Autowand Tim.
Da hätte ich jetzt richtig mit rumgeprotzt, aber leider, leider, leider.
Meine Geschichte erzählen von dir auf der Autobahn? Früher, also als du noch in Millennium warst.
Ach da kann man auch rauswachsen.
Geschichten.
Ich dachte, man bleibt Millennial forever von der Autobahn? Als ich kenne andere Geschichten, aber nicht von.
Möchtest nicht, dass ich die Geschichte erzähle. Wir äh.
So. Aber das war ja auch äh ah das war dann ohne Führerschein.
Was? Ich weiß von,
Sag mal so, es war nicht Teil der Prüfung.
Eine überdurchschnittliche Leistung.
Das auf jeden Fall. Ist nur nicht geprüft worden. Lass uns lieber Politik reden.
Okay, so. Ja, lass uns mal langsam die Laune wieder ein bisschen runterkochen. Das geht ja hier, das wird ja hier ein bisschen zu bunt.
Ähm Patrick Breyer war ja letzte Woche äh zu Gast vorletzte Woche,
Hat über die Zerschwörung des digitalen Briefgeheimnisses sich beklagt. Soweit beklagt, dass er jetzt direkt eine Klage,
gegen Chatkontrolle eingereicht hat, aber in Form einer Unterlassungsklage gegen,
Facebook, weil sie das im Facebook Messenger quasi jetzt schon machen. Also die Verdachtslose automatisierte,
Durchsuchung von privaten Chatverläufen und Fotos? Gleichzeitig ist das passiert,
was äh Patrick befürchtet hatte und da war ja jetzt auch nicht der Einzige, der es befürchtet hat, nämlich die EU-Kommission hat einen Vorschlag unterbreitet für eine Richtlinie,
Und in dieser Rehschiene ähm kommt vor die Chatkontrolle.
Was steht da jetzt genau drin? Wir müssen jedes Mal in dieser Sendung hauptsächlich damit ich das nochmal verstehe mhm erklären was es überhaupt eine EU-Richtlinie,
Und was bedeutet das äh also was sind so die die die Eigenschaften hm weil es gibt ja das andere, das also das eine ist eine Richtlinie, das heißt sie muss in,
Nationale Gesetzgebung.
Umgesetzt werden, genau. Im Gegensatz zu der Grundverordnung, die sofort überall in gleicher Form mit exakt demselben Gesetzestext gilt.
Und das heißt also es gibt jetzt die oder der der Vorschlag ist, dass es eine Richtlinie geben soll, dass die Mitgliedsstaaten der Europäischen Union,
was machen und dabei natürlich noch ein bisschen Freiraum haben in der Umsetzung.
Genau. Ähnliche Ausgangssituation wie bei der Upload-Filtergeschichte bei. Das war auch eine Richtlinie.
Artikel 13 war auch eine eine.
Richtlinie.
Das meiste ist eigentlich Richtlinie.
Und was steht da jetzt drin?
Also wir haben da ja schon relativ lange drauf gewartet. Das ist die ähm langfristige Lösung zu der Abweichung von der ePrivacy-Verordnung, die wir im letzten Jahr bekommen haben. Also letztes Jahr, wir erinnern uns,
Wir dürfen freiwillig scannen, nicht verschlüsselte Kommunikation?
Nicht wir, sondern die die Anbieter. Genau, weil also äh erklär das ruhig noch mal in Ruhe. Es war eigentlich verboten. Diese Scans waren nicht erlaubt.
Eigentlich waren diese Scans nicht erlaubt und das haben sie dann sozusagen nachträglich, würde ich mal so sagen, geregelt und ähm es wurde ihnen erlaubt freiwillig Kommunikation zu scannen.
Damals hat äh haben viele schon gesagt, pass auf, pass auf, die erlauben das jetzt
Die Ausnahme von der e-Privacy richtige und nächstes Jahr kommt die Verpflichtung. Ja also als erstes müssen wir es erstmal
nicht mehr illegal machen und im zweiten Schritt werden wir alle dazu verpflichten, das zu tun. Und genau das,
Ist es jetzt passiert.
Genau, das ist jetzt passiert und das ist auch noch was anderes passiert, also es ist nicht nur die langfristige Lösung zu dieser Abweichung von der e-Privacy-Verordnung, sondern es ist auch eine Spezifizierung für den Digital Services Act, über den ihr ja letztes Mal mit Patrick
lang und breit geredet hast. Das heißt, es betrifft nicht nur dieses Chatkontrollen-Thema, sondern halt auch alle,
Provider in Anbieterinnen und so weiter. Also alles, was wir im Digital Service Act verhindern konnten, ähm kommt jetzt sozusagen noch mal wieder,
in unsere Richtung.
Ich dachte, also das muss man ein bisschen genauer erklären. Ich dachte, digital Service ist, hätten wir jetzt hinter uns.
Nee, leider nicht. Also diese neue Richtlinie ist eine sogenannte Lexspezialist. Das ist eine Spezifizierung zu den bisherigen Sachen, die im Digital des Services
drinstehen und die gelten dann sozusagen statt dem, was eigentlich im Digital Service Act dazu drinsteht.
Ach, aha. Was ist denn das für eine rechtliche Finte? Also ist das normal irgendwie.
Gesetze können immer, das ist ja die Sache, dass du mit dem neuen Gesetz kannst du neue Sachen spezifizieren, ausarbeiten, selber die letzte Änderung gilt.
Okay. Also ist das jetzt nur ein Refinement des DSA oder ist es nochmal etwas anderes, was irgendwie denen überstimmt?
Würde fast sagen, beides.
Ja also beides. Also ich glaube, das ist im im DSA eher generalistisch gehalten. Das ist jetzt in diesem in dieser Richtlinie auch wieder so und ähm jetzt ist es in dieser Richtlinie sozusagen weiter ausspezifiziert.
Also ich würde sagen im Digital Services Act geht es um Dienste. Es ist alles alles Internet und die haben ja auch gesagt hier neues Internet und so,
In diesem Ding geht es schon eigentlich um sexuelle Gewalt an Kindern,
Ne, also das ist quasi halt eigentlich den klaren Fokus, aber das betrifft natürlich wieder ganz viel. Das betrifft weder Dienste, das heißt unter dieser Ausgangsperspektive von,
Was könnte man tun, was sollte man tun zu sexuellem Missbrauch äh von Kindern, zu Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellungen was gibt's da zu tun? Und das wirkt sich natürlich wieder auf alle möglichen Dienste aus und dementsprechend.
Hat dieses Ding auch einen Namen, also wie.
Die Richtlinie zum Schutz von Kindern.
Oh. Schön einfach.
Im Internet. Also es gibt jetzt diesen neuen, schönen Swort. Wir haben ja vorher immer über Seasem geredet und es gibt jetzt eine neue, schöne Abkürzung, die heißt OCSA, also teilt sexual of use. Genau.
Oxer.
Die ändern auch noch ihre Akronyme?
Ja. Das wäre ja langweilig sonst. Es ist wirklich Oxer in den neuen Dingen jetzt. Es heißt ey ja.
Ist das wirklich Oxa in dem neuen Ding jetzt? Es heißt okay, no it. Oxer, super. Muss man ja auch immer up to date bleiben.
Und wie hieß das Ding vorher nochmal und was war der erste andere.
Also früher hat man über Season geredet, was Charles Sexual BUS-Material wäre.
Genau. Es kommt teilweise noch dieses Season Wording dadrin vor, aber grundsätzlich ist das bezieht sich diese Richtlinie auf OCSA.
Okay, Boxer. Oxer kann man sich gut merken. Okay, das heißt, diese sozusagen so eine Unterrichtslinie, die das sozusagen noch mal genauer oder die die für sich steht, aber alles andere beeinflusst.
Ja, genau.
Dinge nochmal selber regeln darf.
Also wie muss ich mir das vorstellen? Die haben ja eigentlich gedacht, sie haben sie klären jetzt mit dem DSA,
bestimmte Dinge ein für alle Mal und als dieser Teige gescheitert ist, ist einfach die EU-Kommissarin, wie heißt sie denn noch mal?
Eva Johansen.
Ich dachte, das wäre von der ähm von der Kommissionspräsidentin.
Ach so, du meinst äh unsere beste Freundin? Äh Ursula.
Äh Ursula Zensursula von der Leyen einen Dieb und Eva die sind jetzt dann hingekommen und haben gesagt, ach so ja DSA wunderbar, dass wir drüber geredet haben, hier ist nochmal eine Richtlinie.
Ja, in die in den Richtlinien geht's jetzt ja nicht pauschal um alles, was mit Märkten zu tun hat und mit Diensten zu tun hat, sondern halt ja eigentlich nur um Kindesmissbrauch.
Und nichts anderes.
Genau, aber das, wenn man da jetzt was gegen tun möchte und so ausufern, wie die sich das überlegt haben, was man da tun könnte, dann hat das natürlich wieder Auswirkungen auf sehr viele Dinge, die auch schon vom Digital Services Act berührt wurden und jetzt aber nochmal ganz anders berührt werden,
so ein bisschen die Situation in der wir uns jetzt befinden.
So, was,
Wir hatten mehrere Befürchtungen hinsichtlich einer solchen Richtlinie. Ähm der Begriff Chatkontrolle wird,
Seit Längerem dabei geprägt, ich glaube, kam also ich hatte den Eindruck, dass er ursprünglich so von Patrick Breier,
Eingeführt wurde oder zumindest ähm in den Breiten Sprachgebrauch übernommen wurde. Ähm wo wir von,
KI-Systemen, Bilderkennungssystemen, Grooming-Erkennung und was nicht alles für Fantasien gesprochen haben. Was, welche Befürchtungen sind jetzt eigentlich,
wahr geworden.
Ja, so ziemlich alle kann man dazu sagen, nur dass sie's wie immer nicht so richtig da reingeschrieben haben. Also wir werden jetzt, wenn wir das Ganze Ding durchsuchen, nicht direkt die Beschreibung von Chatkontrolle, wie wir sie verstehen, finden,
Sie halten sich das so ein bisschen offen,
hinzu kommt noch was wir halt nicht so kommen sehen haben, dass es halt nicht nur um die Erkennung geht, also klar,
Das war ja klar, sondern auch darum, dass sie's löschen und äh auch,
Können und ähm das ist sozusagen ein bisschen neu, das heißt Netzsperre Revisited ist auch in diesem Gesetzesentwurf,
mit drin.
Was genau äh können Sie jetzt blocken?
Das die Antwort ist, es kommt drauf an,
Ähm,
Also, wenn man's uns noch mal von ganz vorne aufwickelt, ist es so, dass alle Anbieterinnen und Provider und so weiter ein Risiko Assessment machen müssen,
indem Sie schauen, wie hoch die Gefahr ist, dass,
Kinder pornographische Darstellung beziehungsweise Missbrauchsdarstellungen über ihre Plattform verteilt,
werden und dann müssen sie basierend auf diesem Risiko Assessment entsprechend Medikation dafür einführen.
Wer macht dieses Risiko Assessment?
Das machen die selber. Ähm das Ding ist aber, sie sind dann sozusagen dafür haftbar zu machen,
Und ähm es gibt aber dann eine Behörde, die das kontrolliert und wenn die sagt,
Ja, schönes Risikoassessment haben Sie da, aber das, was Sie an Maßnahmen eingeleitet haben, um das zu motivieren,
das reicht uns noch nicht, dann können die anordnen, dass bestimmte Maßnahmen eingeleitet werden, also zum Beispiel scannen in einer bestimmten Art und Weise, Blocken,
löschen, filtern, dass die ganze Bandbreite, die wir schon öfter mal gehört haben.
Mhm. Und das betrifft jetzt den Bereich der Chats. Also des gesamten Internets.
Genau, also es betrifft alle. Nicht nur Messengeranbieter, sondern Hoster, Provider, alles. Auch die kleinsten Provider ähm können davon betroffen sein oder sind davon betroffen, wenn das denn kommt.
Äh ich glaube FM vier war das, so ein Artikel zugeschrieben, dass so die spannenden Sachen eigentlich sind das sind, was nicht drinsteht, dass halt anscheinend üblicherweise solche Gesetze so ein Scope haben von,
in diesem abgegrenzten Bereich gilt das und der ist da nicht so richtig oder das sind so vier Punkte, die so relativ schwammig, wenn du ein Provider bist oder,
letzten Endes, also ich ich müsste jetzt nachgucken, aber so ein bisschen letzten Endes, wenn du wenn da Konten sind und Menschen miteinander reden, also extrem weit, das heißt letztendlich eigentlich für alles, was irgendwie mit Daten und Menschen und Kommunikation und Inhalten jongliert, wäre davon wird vermutlich betroffen.
Inklusive App Stores muss man noch dazu.
Was du dir vorstellen kannst wäre irgendwie.
Ah die App Stores noch mit in die Haftung zu nehmen äh hat sich ja scheint sicher ein ich als die äh
Brauchbare Strategie im Umgang mit Telegram halt erwiesen zu haben, zu sagen, okay pass auf äh äh ist in Ordnung, wenn ihr nicht auf unsere Briefe antwortet, aber hm dann müsst ihr dann reden wir halt mit Google und Apple und sehen zu, dass wir euch aus dem
App Store rausbringen. Das heißt, das ist das hat sich natürlich erwiesen, als der übelste,
Oder als der als der schärfste Hebel, den man gegenüber so irgendjemanden irgendwelchen App-Anbieterinnen hat, die sich nicht irgendwie an die Regeln halten. Ähm,
Jetzt müssen wir noch ein bisschen,
glaube ich trotzdem, weil wir einer in einer neuen Sendung sind, nochmal genauer erklären ähm so ein paar Use cases also WhatsApp ist betroffen,
Webhoster ist betroffen. Mambel Chat oder sonstige Dinge, Games, Chats sind betroffen,
Weil sie grundsätzlich immer erstmal geeignet sind Bits von,
Person A zu Person B zu schieben und damit grundsätzlich zu einem sehr breiten Austausch von beispielsweise Bild, Text oder Tonmaterialien geeignet sind.
Das ist glaube ich auch die Sache, also das haben die natürlich auch nicht so genau aufgeschrieben. Ähm wenn ich jetzt hier in habe eine Zusammenfassung gemacht, äh was das vermutlich, was da im Gesetzesentwurf drinsteht. Hier steht es jetzt als publicly avalible interpersonal Communication Services.
Also das ist der erste Punkt von vier und das ist halt einfach nur zwei Menschen reden. Kommunizieren.
Sobald sie einen Service.
Sitzt vor allem noch nicht mal die Fähigkeit voraus Bilder übertragen zu können, sondern.
Nein, nein, nein,
Gottes Willen erreichte. Also wie gesagt, es geht dann ja später auch noch um Anbahnungsversuche von Kriminellen in Richtung von Kindern, das heißt da geht es dann um auch um Text. Also es geht um alles eigentlich. Also es geht um Texte,
Es geht um Bilder. Wir also wir reden hier eigentlich von allem, wo irgendwie Menschen kommunizieren, wo Menschen Dateien hosten,
Also und das ist auch meine Next Cloud. Ähm wir haben in den Vorbereitungen haben wir auch mal gewitzelt, was denn jetzt eigentlich äh,
ein Thunderbird und eine eigene E-Mail-Server sind. Also es haben wir jetzt halt natürlich nicht mehr aufgeschrieben, ob das das jetzt wäre oder nicht, aber ähm ich halte das für nicht unwahrscheinlich, dass man da auch sagen kann, ey, irgendwie wird hier auch kommuniziert. Also ne, muss man dann gucken, aber das ist,
das das, was hier der Gesetzesentwurf ist so schwammig, dass da potenziell alles Mögliche reinrutschen könnte später noch.
Habt ihr den Eindruck, dass es mehr ein Unfall ist oder Absicht?
Das ist voller Absicht. Also das ist ähm diese Richtlinie hat sich ja mehrfach nach hinten verschoben, also eigentlich sollte die ja schon Anfang des Jahres kommen und es gab da auch einige Unstimmigkeiten in der EU-Kommission selber und,
Es liegt
sehr nahe, dass sie das so lange herausgezögert haben, um es möglichst ich sage mal schwammig, aber wasserdicht machen zu können, um sich möglichst wenig angreifbar zu machen, weil sie dann immer sagen können, na ja,
Steht da aber gar nicht drin, was ihr hier uns anprangert.
Das ist ja ein alter Trick, den wir von den Upload-Filtern kennen und mit denen ich weiß nicht, ob ähm,
Herr Dochter ist, damit ist Axel Voss durchgekommen. Diese Richtlinie wurde verabschiedet, dass er immer gesagt hat, das steht nirgendwo Uploadfilter drin,
Die Formulierung war äh Plattformen müssen Maßnahmen ergreifen, die verhindern. Ja und es gibt nur einen,
denkbaren Weg, das zu tun und das ist eben beim Upload,
zu prüfen und damit ähm zu filtern. Das ist also jetzt auch die Vorgabe,
Bei dieser Richtlinie und jetzt müssen wir,
vielleicht bleiben wir mal an einem Beispiel, indem wir jetzt wirklich einfach mal einen massenhaften Chat, ne? Nehmen wir vielleicht einfach WhatsApp, weil die sind sehr eindeutig davon betroffen. Wir haben jetzt etabliert, okay es sind,
Potenziell alle betroffen, aber nehmen wir mal einen den viele neue Hörerinnen unseres Podcasts vielleicht noch nutzen. WhatsApp.
Jede WhatsApp-Nachricht soll also jetzt inhaltlich geprüft werden, müssen potenziell auf,
Anbahnungsversuche oder den Austausch illegalen Material also spezifischen Oxer.
Gibt es denn eine Menge Fälle, die daraufhin deuten, dass WhatsApp nun der neue Kern des Oxer ist.
Ich glaube, das ist die klassische Sache von eigentlich weiß es niemand so genau, aber alles, was wir sehen, zeugt auf Nein.
Weil ähm das also generell alles, was was wir gehört haben, wir haben uns auch ein bisschen im Vorfeld mit Menschen aus Kinderschutzorganisationen unterhalten,
mit äh und auch sonst dann versucht, möglichst viel zu dem Thema zu lesen und alles, was man so liest, Leute darauf verhindern, sagt auch die Polizei, das ist eigentlich mehr der Trend dahin geht,
man ähm als als Krimineller das Material selber schon mal verschlüsselt und dann aufn Hoster hochlädt und dann in irgendwelchen aufs Guren Foren die Links dazu teilt,
Und dafür ist jetzt WhatsApp erstmal überhaupt nicht geeignet, weil es erstens,
Soweit ich weiß, kein Hosting von Dateien anbietet, das andere nicht angemeldete Menschen in großer Masse auf diese Datei zugreifen können.
Also du hast eine one two.
Super many.
Nicht ganz so viele many aber einfach öffentlich bereitstellen ist mit WhatsApp jetzt nicht sehr nennenswert möglich.
Dazu ist es erstmal nicht besonders gut geeignet und dann also ist halt die Frage, wofür braucht man das? Ich glaube nicht, dass das das große Problem ist.
Also selbst wenn es so wäre, ja, dass das große Problem müsste man ja trotzdem noch anerkennen, dass es Milliarden von WhatsApp-Nachrichten,
in der europäischen Union am Tag gibt, die potenziell nicht,
äh diesem Raster entsprechend. Werde es ein schweres Problem ist und vielleicht auch ein Problem mit sehr viel mehr Opfern als äh wir uns wünschen oder bereit sind zu tolerieren,
immer noch ein sehr seltenes Problem, wenn man es auf die einzelnen Nachricht bezieht, die versendet wird.
Und hier passiert jetzt natürlich also angenommen, wir würden jetzt anfangen da jede einzelne Nachricht anzugucken, passiert natürlich das Gleiche,
immer wenn man mit einem KI-basierten Entscheidungssystem sehr seltene Fälle sucht, weil dann hat man einfach eine sehr kleine Heunadel, einen sehr großen Steckhau ähm äh Heuhaufen. Stecknadel Heuhaufen und dann ist,
Du hast gerade schon gesagt, ungefähr eine halbe Milliarden Nachrichten pro Tag. Ähm alle Menschen, die mitbasierten Entscheidungssystemen arbeiten, da sind ja typischerweise, sind Fehlerraten,
vielleicht dann irgendwie, dass wir in einem Prozent der Fälle eine Entscheidung etwas fälschlicherweise erkannt wird, wenn wir jetzt mal von gutem System ausgehen, dann ist es eins von tausend, vielleicht auch eins von 10tausend, aber wir sehen also in diesen Größenordnungen von,
Entscheidungssystem wäre wenn das Ding jedes zehntausendste Mal ähm etwas erkennt, wäre das trotzdem eine enorme jeden Tag.
Eine enorme Anzahl an Nachrichten, die fälschlicherweise erkannt werden würden und da kann man natürlich noch sagen, ja, vielleicht wird die Technik noch besser, aber wenn man jetzt äh in jedem Foto und in jedem Text,
nach solchen Dingen sucht, ist ist es glaube ich mindestens Stand jetzt oder in unserer Dekade, in der wir gerade leben, relativ wahrscheinlich, dass da also,
um viele Größenordnungen mehr, fälschlicherweise erkanntes Material bei rauskommt als tatsächliches.
Ich würde das jetzt also ich denke das das muss man immer hier unterscheiden die äh Detektionsfälle es gibt ein sehr einfachen Fall und das ist das bekannte.
Sorry, da das ist natürlich viel einfacher.
Also nicht sorry, sondern wir wir sortieren das jetzt mal. So das bekannte Material, da gibt's Datenbanken von da gibt es das ähm,
äh diese ähm wie heißt das Foto,
Foto DNA, ne, von Microsoft, die mit sehr, sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit keine dieser Wahrscheinlichkeiten ist eins, aber mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit in der Lage sind bekanntes Material wiederzuerkennen.
Genau und was hier wichtig ist zu sagen, ähm auch das steht in dieser Richtlinie, dass wir auf EU-Ebene eine eigene Behörde einrichten, die ähm dann auch eine entsprechende Datenbank anlegt und,
So lässt es vermuten, ähm auch mit unseren lieben Freunden von Europol.
Zusammenarbeitet. Ähm wir erinnern uns, die Europol-Menschen haben einen riesengroßen Datensee im Moment, dem sie nicht, bei dem sie nicht genau wissen, was da drin ist und jetzt dürfen sie ja sozusagen die Daten länger aufbewahren, bis sie rausgefunden haben.
Da drin ist.
Welchen See meinst du da jetzt genau?
Also Europol hat Datenbanken und sie wurden im Prinzip gefragt. Sag mal, was habt ihr da eigentlich alles drin?
Und haben jetzt sozusagen eine Ausnahmeregelung von den Aufbewahrungspflichten von der Datenschutzgrundverordnung bekommen, dass sie die Datenlänge aufheben dürfen, weil sie ja nicht sagen können, was da drin ist.
Okay, aber äh.
Aha. Weil's verschlüsselt ist. Oder weil sie nicht sagen dürfen, was drin.
Weil's zu viel ist, weil sie einfach keinen Überblick haben und sie dem Ganzen gar nicht Herr werden.
Wenn du einfach genug da, wenn's zu viel Daten hast, gilt Datenschutz nicht mehr.
So ungefähr.
So viel kannst du ja eh nix mit anfangen.
Muss man ehrlich es gibt, das gibt ein ähm NPA-Vortrag dazu. Den teste ich mal ins Pad und dann.
Den nehmen wir mal mit auf. Jetzt würde ich aber noch ganz kennen, einmal weiter bleiben, also bekanntes Material zu erkennen, ist sagen wir mal eine eine lösbare Aufgabe und da sind wir im Zweifelsfall in einem ähm,
Fehlerquotenbereich weit hinterm Komma im Prozentbereich aber auch hinterm Komma, das war jetzt gerade dein Argument Viktor ähm,
führt das noch zu riesigen Fehlerquoten in Anbetracht der großen Mengen
wo diese Fehlerquote eben zutrifft. Ne, wenn du jetzt halt eine halbe Milliarde hast und davon zu 99,99Prozent keinen Fehler machst, dann machst du eben zu 0,00 ein Prozent ein Fehler und das ist auf die halbe Milliarde gerechnet, eben doch sehr viel.
Ja, ich ich kenne mich jetzt nicht genau mit den konkreten Spezifikationen von Foto, DNA und sowas aus. Ich kann mir das sogar vorstellen, dass diese Erkennung von bekanntem Material, dass die ziemlich gut funktionieren würde.
Richtung eins, ne? Jetzt schauen wir uns mal an äh die gehen aber natürlich weiter und sagen,
Grooming, ja, erwachsene Person äh macht sich an Kind ran. Ich glaube, da wird natürlich die Erkennungsrate sehr davon abhängig sein, ob ich weiß,
Wie das Alter der beiden Personen ist. Ja, wenn ich diese Information nicht habe, dann glaube ich nicht, dass man eine
dass eine KI irgendwo nennenswerte Erkennungsquoten hat äh wie ob jetzt Häschen und was sich Leute so vielleicht schreiben ähm nun ein Anbahnungsversuch ist oder nicht.
Das heißt, da da ist so eine sehr, sehr hast du schon mal eine sehr schwere Aufgabe. Da hatte Microsoft, glaube ich, mal gesagt, so, sie haben irgendwie 80 Prozent Erkennungsrate gehabt.
Positiv oder negativ?
Ich habe nur die 80 Prozent gesehen, ja, das heißt 20 Prozent Fehlerrate, das heißt, jeder fünfte falsch.
Aber jeder Fünfte nicht erkannt.
Äh genau, jeder fünfte nicht erkannt, was natürlich dramatisch wäre. Was ich richtig spannend finde, ist,
Die wollen ja auch also Text lässt sich relativ einfach analysieren, wenn du ein paar Meterdaten dazu hast, geht's?
Aber neues Material halleluja Freunde. Das wird gut.
Ich glaube auch da wird es dann richtig kompliziert.
Also das Interessante wird natürlich sein, gerade bei
unbekannten Material von Fotos muss man natürlich irgendwie so darüber gehen, so wie alt ist die Person auf dem Bild, wie viel Haut ist zu sehen und so weiter und so fort.
Ähm nun wissen wir aber, von den Ermittlungsbehörden, dass natürlich Jugendliche sich schon ganz gerne mal,
Nacktbilder zusenden.
Ihre ihre Entdeckungen am eigenen Körper miteinander teilen.
Genau so und das wird natürlich dazu führen, dass äh das natürlich,
alles auch erkannt wird und was man dazu wissen muss, ist, dass das für Minderjährige auch strafbar ist, also das muss nachverfolgt werden, also.
Kein Antragsdelikt, sondern muss verfolgt werden und ist heute schon für den größeren Teil der Strafverfahren in dem Bereich verantwortlich. So sehr schön wird das ja dann, wenn sehr jung aussehende Männer.
Oder sich.
Ähm sich Bilder schicken untereinander, um mal wie wir das auch machen. Ab und an, nicht so oft.
Einfach selbst gerne auch welche.
Not toself.
Das ist ja dann auch ein Anbahnungsversuch. Ähm sodass also dieser gesamte Bereich selbst wenn man davon ausginge, dass die Erkennungsquoten äußerst gering sind, darf man nicht vergessen, dass diese Filtermechanismen,
jeder einzelne dieser Nachrichten prüfen mit einer entsprechend nennenswerten Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit.
Ist ja noch viel schlimmer. Es sind ja nicht nur die Jugendlichen betroffen, sondern auch irgendwelche jungen Eltern, wo man sich vielleicht gegenseitig die Urlaubsbilder oder die Bilder mit dem Kind aus der Badewanne schickt oder die an die Großeltern schickt.
Oder die noch schlimmer die Großeltern fragen danach. Schickt doch mal ein Bild von.
Ja.
Ja. Wie ist der so am.
Oh oh da hast du aber ganz schnell große Probleme. Nein, hast du nicht, weil die EU-Behörde wird ja das ausgeleitete Material prüfen.
Da müssen genau da äh kommt dann entsprechende Bilderberge türmen sich da auf, wo dann wieder irgendwelche Menschen durchgucken müssen. Was mir wie mir ist grade eingefallen, was ich auch gerade noch sagen wollte noch kurz zu zu wohin, dass ähm du hast äh einen richtigen Riecher gehabt mit der Text,
Also mit der für die Texterkennung zu wissen, wie alt die Leute sind. Natürlich haben diese Leute auch diese Idee gehabt und das führt natürlich dazu, dass man,
de facto eine Kleinnamenspflicht. Also die ganzen ähm Geister, die ganzen untoten Geister jetzt politischer Debatten erstehen hier wieder auf, weil das geht natürlich nur, wenn du,
alle Leute zwingst, ihr echtes Alter zu sagen und das geht dann wieder nur,
Wenn sie nicht mehr Pseudonym oder anonym unterwegs sein dürfen, sondern ein Foto von Imperso gemacht haben müssen. Das heißt also, es hat auch Auswirkungen auf,
soziale Netzwerke und andere Bereiche des Internets. Das ist ja schon eine eine Debatte der letzten 20 Jahre. Wollen wir Anonymität erlauben im Internet oder wollen wir eine Kleinnahmenpflicht für alle und auch an diese Sachen, die kommen da auf einmal wieder,
Ganz anderen Gesichtspunkt, aber ich glaube, das ist wichtig, das zu verstehen, dass das wirklich so viele Teilbereiche vom Internet auch prägen würde ähm und verändern würde.
Jetzt kann man also man kann glaube ich heutzutage eine Age verification durchführen ohne,
Dass man tatsächlich die vollständigen Daten zeigen muss. Es gibt einmal diese Prüfziffer, hatte ich glaube ich auch schon mal hier erzählt, ne? Äh wo du.
Mhm. Total sicher.
Genau du also du hast eine Prüfziffer, die ist zwischen null und neun die quasi verifiziert, ob deine also mit der du quasi deine Altersprüfung,
äh durchführen kannst. Ähm
Wie gesagt, die liegt zwischen, nee, die liegt zwischen 0 und neun. Also, ich habe mir gar nicht die Mühe gemacht, den Algorithmus zu verstehen, weil ich gemerkt habe, ist einfacher. Null eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun durchzuprobieren. Ähm es gibt auch mit der E-ID natürlich,
theoretische Möglichkeiten eine Altersprüfung durchzuführen, aber was wir sehen werden, das muss man ja auch bei solchen Gesetzen sagen, die werden immer ausgeweitet,
selbst wenn man am Anfang noch vielleicht eine Altersverifikation macht, die zu umgehen ist oder die, sage ich mal, zu auszutricksen ist, dann wird genau das zum Anlass genommen,
jenes eben auch äh,
zu verhindern oder eben zu schärfen. Und ähm bei allen Gesetzen kennen wir das ja dummerweise leider, dass sie eben nicht bei ihrem spezifischen,
Fokus bleiben. Insofern denke ich, dass sehr klar, auch wenn wieder mal, ne, das klassische Salamitaktik heute gesagt werden kann, nein, da steht keine Klarnamenpflicht drin.
Die die Gleise in genau diese Richtung oder die Weichen in diese Richtung gestellt werden.
Ja und ähm bei dieser Richtlinie ist halt auch besonders interessant, dass sie so generell gehalten ist, dass man die sehr schnell an Dinge anpassen kann. Also der der Gefahr eines die Gefahr eines Dammbruches ist hier noch viel höher, weil sie eben so schwammig,
formuliert wurde und dass man ganz schnell sagen kann, ja okay, wir machen das jetzt auch genauso für Terror. Zum Beispiel.
Mhm. Oder äh Urheberrechts ähm Verstöße,
es ist ja auch Eigenschaft der Richtlinie, dass sie eben in Interpretation der einzelnen Länder,
ähm in nationale Gesetzgebung umgesetzt wird, sodass wir potenziell eine Situation haben, in der Ungarn,
Äh Italien, Spanien, Frankreich unterschiedliche Gesetzgebungen haben, die sich aber alle auf ja irgendwelche Konzerne ähm,
Die potenziell nicht,
bereit sind so was wie die Europäische Union jetzt in in unterschiedlichen Staaten zu unterteilen, sondern dass wir dann hier ein Race to the,
Bottom haben oder einen wie auch immer man das sieht. Teilweise soll das gelöst werden, dass die EU-Behörde diese Kontrollen macht, ne.
Ja, genau, also es wird eine neue EU-Behörde geschaffen,
also diese Datenbank aufbaut, dass technisch unterstützt. Ähm und sozusagen da, ich sage mal, in Anführungsstrichen, beratend zur Seite steht. Alle EU-Länder müssen aber auch,
Behörden benennen, die kontrollieren und äh dann auch sozusagen ausführend sind.
Und ich glaube, was nochmal spannend ist zu erzählen ist, dass,
es tatsächlich ist einfach eine komplizierte Situation, weil dieses Gesetz so wahnsinnig schwammig ist. Also wir wissen, was die Intention dahinter ist. Die wollen das verhindern. So die wollen also ne die die Intention, dass man das ist soll technisch nicht mehr möglich sein, sich solches Material,
Mit den ganzen Plattformen, auf die man über EU äh Juristin zugreifen kann, ne,
Und das Spannende ist, dass ähm auch aktuell ist es gar nicht so schwer von der Gegenseite zu sagen,
Ist doch alles total Quatsch, was ihr euch hier ausdenkt. Wir haben noch gar nicht gesagt, dass wir alles äh Chat kontrollieren wollen und ihr seid da jetzt total paranoid und,
sprecht ihr von irgendwelchen großen Internetumwälzungen, ist doch alles überhaupt kein Problem und es steht sogar im Gesetz drin, dass das alles unter höchster Abschätzung zum Datenschutz und nur wenn es wirklich angemessen ist und
das Gesetz diktiert, macht es bitte nur ganz wenig und ähm und ich glaube, das ist total wichtig, dass.
Das weiß jetzt natürlich niemand, weil es einfach nicht da schwarz auf weiß steht, aber wir halten das für extrem wahrscheinlich,
tatsächlich passieren wird und ich glaube, wieder aus so einer ähm Perspektive bei den Upload-Filtern, dass man sich eigentlich immer nur fragen muss, wer haftet denn, wenn's schief geht,
Denn ähm wenn man jetzt so ein Filtersystem, die die Möglichkeit so ein Filtersystem aufbaut, zum Beispiel wie bei den Upload-Filtern und sagt, du hast aber ein Problem, wenn du dich verschätzt hast, ähm wenn das hier jetzt genauso wieder passiert,
Dann kann man sich das ja eigentlich gar nicht als Unternehmen leisten zu sagen, nee, wir haben keinen Bock auf die Filter, wir gehen, also wir gehen das Risiko ein,
Und ähm deshalb halten wir's einfach für sehr wahrscheinlich, dass diese Risikoabwägung und vor allem dadurch, dass das halt alles so schwammig ist, das wird irgendeine EU-Zentrum,
Wer weiß, wer da sitzt, ist an Europol angekoppelt vermutlich. Ich glaube, dass so uns.
Wir wissen es noch nicht genau, aber die Vermutung liegt nah, einfach auch aus Infrastrukturgründen.
Ja, also ich glaube, Sie werden mindestens von Europol unterstützt oder so. Also eine irgendwie eureponahes Zentrum, das dann Abwägung dazu damit beauftragt ist, Abwägung zwischen digitalen Freiheitsrechten und äh Rechtsdurchsetzungen zu treffen,
Und äh das könnte natürlich,
dass man einfach sehr viel sehr viel diese Mechanismen einsetzt. Ich glaube, wir haben's schon gesagt, ne? Im Prinzip wäre ein ein Maßnahmenkatalog wurde da aufgemacht und eines davon ist eben, dass man Menschen sagt, er kennt das Zeug bitte. Wir sagen nicht wie,
könnt ihr euch selber überlegen aber wir möchten, dass ihr das erkennt ja.
Noch viel schlimmer und wenn ihr euch das nicht leisten könnt, das selber zu bauen, um das zu erkennen, dann stellen wir euch gerne Software zur Verfügung, um das zu erkennen.
Ja die aber ne also gehen wir irgendwo Software einkaufen und dann die bitte alle auf euren Servern und äh dann macht ihr das und dann müssen alle Leute an im Prinzip an jeden Userdatenstrom fremdes Software, wo sie nicht reingucken können, dranhalten,
Also das ist äh also wie diese Umsetzung aussehen soll, ist mir ein bisschen, also ich finde es vor allem fast ein bisschen frech zu sagen, wir wollen das Ergebnis, also wir wollen die Utopie, aber wir sagen euch nicht wie,
Und deshalb sind wir aber nicht für negative Folgen verantwortlich, weil wir ja nicht gesagt haben wie also ich finde, das ist wie wenn du so ein Mafia-Boss sagt, ja hier der Luigi, der soll nicht mehr atmen,
wie du das machst? Also ich habe nichts gesagt. Also, ne? Das ist hier irgendwie Technologie offen.
Ergebnisse sehen. So und äh.
Regelt der Markt.
Ja, gerne. Wenn der Luigi nicht stirbt, stirbst du. Ähm ja, genau, wir werden sehen.
Jetzt ähm,
Müssen wir, glaube ich, sagen, also das ist ein äh denke, wir haben etabliert, das ist ein enormer Aufwand, der da äh und eine sehr weitreichende,
Einschnitt.
In ja was überhaupt? Also viele äh Artikel diskutieren das als das Ende der Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung. Warum eigentlich? Warum ist das jetzt so eine Gefahr für die Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung?
Na ja, also der ganze Witz bei N zu Ende Verschlüsselung ist ja, dass wenn ich zum Beispiel Linus eine Nachricht schicke, wir sicherstellen können, dass nur er und ich den Inhalt dieser Nachricht lesen können.
Und wenn wir jetzt natürlich rausfinden möchten, ob ich äh Linus irgendwas Verbotenes geschickt habe,
Noch nicht. Ähm dann ähm muss ich da natürlich reingucken. So.
Und ähm dementsprechend muss dann halt dieser Content, den ich dir geschickt habe angeschaut werden und festgestellt werden, ja okay, das sind schon wieder Bilder von irgendwelchen Einhörnern,
oder ist es irgendwas verbotenes?
Minderjährige Einhörner.
Genau und das ähm kann man ja dann technisch unterschiedlich.
Umsetzen. Das Einfachste ist natürlich zu sagen, es gibt einfach keine Verschlüsselung mehr, dann können wir da reingucken, alles jut, gar kein Problem. Das,
haben Sie sich jetzt natürlich gut überlegt, dass Sie das nicht machen, weil dann hätten Sie wirklich noch viel größeres Problem, sondern es ist wieder dieser schöne Begriff des Kleinzeit-Scanning.
Aufgetaucht,
kennen wir ja schon ausm letzten Jahr, aus der Apple-Debatte, würde ich mal so sagen und ähm hier wäre es halt dann auch so, dass,
alle Chatnachrichten auf dem Gerät gescannt werden. Ähm also nicht nur die Bilder und dann halt entsprechend,
erstmal wenn's um bekanntes Material geht gegen bekanntes Material abgeglichen wird, da stellt sich dann natürlich die Frage, okay,
Das führt ja anhand von Bildherrs passieren, wo werden dann die Bild-Hashes
abgelegt. Wie ist das mit den Speicherkapazitäten auf dem Telefon und so weiter? Dann haben wir als nächsten Punkt ja dieses Thema Unbekanntes zu erkennen. Das heißt,
Hier ist ja dann die Sache, da werden wir ja irgendwelche Klassefeier haben, die trainiert wurden und dann sagen, ja, das ist gut, das ist böse. Die müssen natürlich auch regelmäßig upgedatet werden,
Das irgendwie Privatsphäre technisch ordentlich machen will, kann ich ja keine Lernergebnisse vom Gerät wieder zurück an meinen Provider leiten. Das heißt.
Alle zentral bei der EU gesammelt.
Ja gut, so kannst du's natürlich auch sehen. Genau und ähm dann ist es natürlich auch so, dass das natürlich gesichtet werden muss. Also es kann ja also,
Es kam auch wieder dieser Fall,
rein, dass das ja nicht direkt an die Ermittlungsbehörde gegebenenfalls weitergeleitet wird, sondern dass der oder die Anbieterin das erstmal sichtet mit Menschen, die da reingucken in dieses ausgeleitete Material und sagen,
Das ist übrigens ein Problem gewesen und das hier nicht.
Und würdest du jetzt also ist ja kein Problem. Wir haben ja alle nichts zu verbergen. So, also warum warum soll ich mich jetzt davon angesprochen fühlen?
Naja, also ich find's schon peinlich, dass man sich so Einhörner anguckt, aber das ist ein spannendes Thema. Es ähm,
Na ja, also ich sage das immer nur so, ich finde, dass unsere Telefone heutzutage das Persönlichste,
sind, was wir eigentlich so haben. Wir tippen da irgendwie alle unsere Gedanken rein, alle unsere Gespräche mit Freunden, Familie oder unseren Partnerinnen und ich glaube, das Wichtigste an dieser Stelle ist halt wirklich, dass wir
unserem Gerät vertrauen können, dass das wirklich nur dann irgendwo hingeht, wenn wir entschieden haben, irgendwo hingehen sollen.
Drauf, dass wir unserem Gerät vertrauen können. Ne, das Grundrecht auf Gewährleistung der Integrität.
Ja das sind die Computer. Ich glaube, das Briefgeheimnis.
Informationstechnischer.
Ein Handy ist auch ein Information.
Also das ist äh das das Grundrecht, dass dein Handy das macht, was du möchtest. Genau. Und nichts anderes.
Äh dass mein Handy das macht, was ich möchte und nichts anderes und die und die Eingriff der der einzige bisherige Eingriff in die Integrität meines Gerätes, der von staatlicher Seite kommt, ist äh Staatstrojaner, ne, Quellen, Telekommunikation,
Überwachung, ja, wo man sagt, wir schaffen eine Schadsoftware, die vor der Verschlüsselung alle Inhalte ausleitet,
Dafür aber nur diejenigen betrifft, die ähm einem spezifischen Ermittlungsverfahren ausgesetzt sind, ne, also da nehmen wir alles,
ähm dafür aber nur bei denen, wo wir einen Verdacht haben. Jetzt machen wir's einfach bei allen, ohne Verdacht,
leiten aber nur aus, wo wir vielleicht einen Verdacht haben.
KI-basierten Staatsmassenstaatstrojaner.
Das ist genau, ist ein KI-basierter Massenstaatstrojaner, der ähm,
nämlich in eine in eine es ist es ist leider tatsächlich wahr.
Damit sollten Sie mal Werbung für dieses Gesetz machen.
Warum nennt ihr das Chatkontrolle?
Haben wir nicht so genannt.
Haben wir vielleicht eine gute für die Kampagne auf EU-Ebene.
Meine, es stellt sich ja jetzt so ein bisschen die Frage, wie geht man damit politisch jetzt eigentlich,
Ich meine, ich habe ja vorhin gefragt ähm denkst du, es ist irgendwie Absicht oder nicht? Hast du gesagt, ja,
ist Absicht, aber Frage ist von wem? Also sicherlich nicht von allen. Ja, also ich kann mir einfach überhaupt nicht vorstellen,
Äh also vielleicht bin ich ja auch naiv so, aber üblicherweise ist es ja so,
werden von wenigen geschrieben und von den meisten äh beschlossen. Na ja erstmal vor allem,
aus Fraktionszwang keiner beschäftigt sich mit allem und so weiter, alle stimmen ab, aber nur die wenigsten arbeiten ja nun wirklich an so etwas, ne? Das heißt, du hast natürlich schon eine
Kontrolle auf die konkrete Umsetzung eines Gesetzesvorschlags im Rahmen einer Arbeitsgruppe oder wer auch immer das jeweils äh vorantreibt und dann
irgendwie voll mit. Der Max äh jetzt Leute geben, die sozusagen,
da eine Absicht äh drin haben, sei es durch die spezifische Formulierung, was man überhaupt will, beziehungsweise eben durch diese spezifische Weglassen.
Zum Beispiel von konkreten Rahmen, wo es angewendet werden darf et cetera. Ne, das lassen wir einfach mal raus und so weiter, dann passt das irgendwie schon. Trotzdem würde ich jetzt nicht sagen,
dass das Ziel hier äh was von,
der Mehrheit äh quasi damit ja geteilt wird, dass sie dass sie dem jetzt zustimmen äh das beabsichtigt, sondern es gibt sozusagen eine Diskrepanz zwischen dem, was irgendwie dieses Gesetz tatsächlich tut und weniger da irgendwie was machen wollen und und das, was die meisten eigentlich denken, vielleicht was es gut ist
tun könnte plus diese ganze Problematik, die wir ja eben auch schon so rausgehört haben.
Eigentlich versteht keiner diese technischen Implikationen, die das hat. Weder was irgendwie für Software erfolgreich zum Einsatz gebracht werden kann
Wo die Software zum Einsatz gebracht werden kann, wer die schreibt, wartet mit Daten befüllt et cetera und äh teilweise ist es absurd, teilweise ist es,
nicht
durchführbar, teilweise ist es halt äh vielleicht durchführbar, aber eben nur auf eine Art und Weise, die völlig unakzeptabel ist, die ihr dann auch wirtschaftliche äh Auswirkungen hat, weil das bedeutet ja dann auch, sich da Marktführer etablieren et cetera, um den man nicht drum herum kommt, et cetera so.
Sprich
Das ist ja dann eigentlich eine Gemengelage, wo man jetzt überlegen muss, wie wie stößt man da jetzt politisch rein und wem macht man jetzt eigentlich auf welche Art und Weise klar, was äh hier eigentlich grade passiert, weil das sieht für mich ja vor allem erstmal
zu einem großen Teil, ich würde mal sagen, das ist so 60 Prozent schlechtes Handwerk für äh eine 30 Prozent verstehen überhaupt nicht, was äh Sache ist und zehn Prozent
sind irgendwie nicht so ja weiß ich nicht fehlgeleitet.
Also ich lasse mich nochmal kurz ausholen. Ich glaube ähm also ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir uns,
ob das als handwerklich schlecht juristisch schlecht geschrieben ist, das kann ich persönlich zum Beispiel gar nicht einschätzen. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die juristisch gesehen extrem viel Mühe darein gemacht haben, um das Wasser dicht und kohärent und vor allem jetzt,
Menschen, die uns schlecht kritisierbar und angreifbar zu machen, weil es eben so,
juristisch schwammig und wenig technisch konkret ist. Ich möchte eigentlich auch niemand was böses unterstellen, was ich mir, was ich persönlich für am plausibelsten halte, ist, dass ähm,
Menschen, die das aufgeschrieben haben, zu wenig technisch konkrete, tiefe Beratung erfahren haben und so ein bisschen sich vor den technischen Fragestellungen,
gerettet haben, indem sie einfach gesagt haben, ist euer Problem nicht unseres? Wir wollen nur Ergebnisse sehen,
Und ähm vielleicht auch damit losgelaufen sind. Es gibt tatsächlich ja auch Zeitdruck, weil diese Übergangsverordnung diesen Dezember ausläuft. Das heißt, es ist natürlich eigentlich auch eine gute Idee zu sagen, okay, da läuft irgendwas aus, lasst uns was Neues machen.
Und sicherlich glaube ich.
Welche und die ePriva ist die richtige Ausnahme. Oder.
Die das Scannen erlaubt.
Das schon vor Längerem plant, meinst du?
Nein, nein, nein, nicht plant, aber es gab eine ein ein Übergangsdokument, was gesagt hat, wenn ihr freiwillig scannen wollt, in unverschlüsselter Kommunikation, dann dürft ihr das.
Und das Ding läuft aus. So und das heißt jetzt, wenn man oder es ist schon ausgelaufen.
Läuft aus. Es läuft.
Weiß es nicht mehr genau. Aber es gibt irgendeine Frist und das ist also aus dieser ähm Ausgangssituation ist es natürlich ja finde ich ist es absolut legitim zu sagen, hey wir brauchen ein neues Gesetz,
Und mein persönlicher Eindruck ist, dass da einfach dann
Mit dieser Ziel von hey lass uns doch mal einfach um da mal richtig was richtig was zu machen. Lasst uns doch uns einfach
technisch unmöglich machen, so Krams zu verschicken. Was benutzen die Leute denn? Messenger, lasst es uns doch mal technisch und möglich machen, so was beim Messenger und Host dann zu verschicken, weil dann Leute einfach sagen, das sind die Sachen, auf die wir einwirken können, dann machen wir das jetzt unmöglich.
Und ich glaube, dass einfach in diesem Prozess das alles aufzubauen nicht genug Menschen früh genug gesagt haben, ey das wenn man das jetzt mal durchspielt,
Äh das funktioniert alles schlecht oder es wird alles total schwierig. Das also das erstmal dazu. Deshalb,
Ich würde sagen, wir müssen jetzt hier nicht Menschen sagen, ihr habt eigentlich geplant den Massenüberwachungsstaat aufzubauen und das ist vorgeschoben. Wir haben auch mit Leuten geredet, die eher aus der Kinderschutzecke kommen,
echt unglücklich waren darüber, dass hier aus deren Perspektive ähm äh Kinderschutzthemen ähm benutzt werden,
Um äh irgendwelche äh digitalpolitischen Überwachungsdinger aufzubauen, wo die sagen, ey, also wenn man was machen möchte, wir hätten so viele andere Ideen, aber nicht das ähm.
Das finde ich, wenn ich da ganz kurz einhaken darf, doch eigentlich den entscheidenden Punkt. Ähm ich würde nicht unbedingt den Leuten, die diesen Vorschlag jetzt machen,
eine böse Absicht unterstellen. Ich glaube, das ist das, was du äh sagen möchtest, aber schauen wir uns mal das Gefüge an, indem sich eine Innenpolitikerin befindet,
Ähm wenn da irgendjemand daherkommt und sagt, hör mal,
Umfragewerte läuft, ja. Haste nicht mal was für die hast du nicht mal Bock, was für die Kinder zu machen? Wer würde denn sich dem Drama aussetzen, so jemanden wegzuschicken?
Oder einen solchen einem solchen Progose entgegenzutreten, ne? Das ist ja ein ein ein Vorschlag, ein eine Idee, egal wer da kommt,
Wenn irgendeine Organisation, die sagt, wir sind hier zum Schutz der Kinder, wir würden gerne mit ihnen sprechen. Wenn du da nicht sofort sagst, passe auf, morgen früh um acht habe ich noch Zeit, dann hast du ja schon, bist ja schon mit einem Fuß abgewählt. Ähm,
Insofern glaube ich schon, dass das hier mit mit guten Intentionen der Weg.
Wie heißt das gepflastert ist, ja, aber das, was ich sehr fürchterlich finde, ist eigentlich und da finde ich, haben wir auch viel zu wenig drüber gesprochen. Das ist nicht das, wie diese Täter vorgehen.
So, was alles, was wir an Kriminalität wissen, funktioniert anders,
Alles, was wir an kriminellen Banden ähm äh irgendwie ausheben, agiert anders. Da gibt's nie,
wieder mal eine kriminelle WhatsApp-Bande hochgenommen. Das gibt's nicht. Es gibt wieder mal eine Darknetbande hochgenommen, kriminelle WhatsApp-Banden gibt's irgendwie nur bei den Bullen.
Vielleicht sollten wir da überlegen, ob wir einen Filter machen, ja und bei Attila Hildmann, aber so, ne? Das das heißt, wir wir wir,
sollten doch sehr viel mehr,
Das Problem erstmal richtig umreißen und deswegen finde ich das so wichtig, dass du sagst ähm es gibt also Kinderschutz,
Organisationen, die diesen Ziel entschieden entgegentreten, zum Beispiel der Deutsche Kinderschutzbund. Mit welcher Argumentation?
Also da hat der Pressesprecher, ich habe das Zitat jetzt nicht mehr vor Augen, aber der Pressesprecher hat gesagt, äh dass das einfach unverhältnismäßig ist. Oder weißt du das noch besser?
Ja genau, also der Kinderschutzbund findet diese Maßnahme unverhältnismäßig im Vergleich sozusagen zu dem Risikoassessment, könnte man fast sagen. Ähm
Das ähm man da aufmachen könnte und ähm ist halt auch der Meinung, dass es halt ganz, ganz viele andere Dinge,
gibt, die man machen kann,
Bevor man sozusagen zu so einer krassen Maßnahme greift und ich glaube, dass fast das Problem ganz gut auf. Es ist halt immer dieses Ding,
sehen viele Menschen natürlich total gerne, dass äh man die Technologie als magisches Ding aus dem Hut zaubern kann und dann sind alle Probleme gelöst,
und ich glaube, das ist auch genau hier passiert.
Wir hatten ja vorhin darüber gesprochen, dass sie schlechte technische Beratung hatten. Ähm diese Gesetzgebung hat quasi ihren eigenen Smudo. In diesem Fall ist es aber nicht Smudo, sondern Ashton Kutscher. Ähm Politik.
Wer ist das.
Das ist der doode wer ist mal K oder wie wir sagen würden Mensch ähm und er.
Oder Sänger oder was.
Genau. Schauspieler, der ist auch von hier die wilden Siebziger oder so hieß diese Fernsehserie. Damit ist er bekannt geworden. Ähm.
Bei mir nicht.
Dafür bist du zu jung. Ähm na ja, auf jeden Fall ähm ist Aschenkutscher äh maßgeblich sozusagen an der Lobbyarbeit,
beteiligt gewesen. Ein kleiner Funfact am Rande, die gleiche PA-Agentur, die die PR für die Ducker-App gemacht hat, hat auch die PR für Eschen Kutscher gemacht.
Am Ende wird die Scheiße auch noch an die Russen verkauft.
Das wissen wir jetzt noch nicht bei den Amerikanern vielleicht ein bisschen unwahrscheinlicher. Aber.
Aber es gibt eine ähm eine ähm eine sportliche Doppelkombi, dass es da.
Das ist sehr interessant, genau.
Genau, das ist da eine NGO gibt, ähm wie so also vorne ist die NGO-Name und das ist wohl quasi zwei Seiten des Zuges und der der hintere Teil heißt ich lässt du besser.
Ich kann dir nicht sagen, wie das Unternehmen heißt, also eigentlich ist das.
Safer heißt das Produkt, glaube ich.
Genau, es heißt Safer und das ist nämlich so, dass Ash ein Kutscher, der massiv investiert hat ähm und Safer tut genau das, was dieser Gesetzesentwurf beschreibt, nämlich,
Scannen und erkennen von Materialien.
Das heißt, wir haben auch mal wieder so eine so eine schöne Doppelkombi von einem wirtschaftlich interessierten Konzern, wo aber irgendwie dran geklebt eine NGO ist und das war auch wieder ganz witzig. Ähm da da komme ich ein kurzer Rückschluss auf, wie ist das eigentlich passiert? Ähm,
ähm Menschen bei Edry äh European european Digital,
Genau im europäische NGO Menschen ähm die waren auch sehr unglücklich, weil sich die entsprechende EU-Innenkommissarin kein einziges Mal
mit Datenschutz ähm Organisationen getroffen hat, in der Vorbereitung von diesem Gesetz, aber zu,
unzähligen Meetings mit Leuten, die sich mit Scanning Technologie verkaufen, die mit Scanning Technologie zu tun haben und unter anderem auch mit. Ähm,
Und äh da also dass da auch wohl in der Vorbereitung und in der Beratung ein starkes Ungleichgewicht bestand ähm und äh natürlich ähm ja.
Es ist es ist wirklich sehr äh traurig zu betrachten, dass äh also wenn man.
Netzpolitik Artikel.
Genau, der man erkennt, man erkennt das Muster, ne, dass jetzt irgendwie so Politikerinnen da sind, die sagen, ach Mensch, ich will mal was machen, ähm
Jetzt würde ich ohne ersten Kutscher zu äh kämen, aber wenn er nicht mehr weiß, wo sein Auto ist, würde ich dem jetzt auch nicht nennenswerte Kompetenz in der Beurteilung von KI-System und äh,
ja der Pädokriminalität äh zuordnen, aber genauso wie so ein Smoothu rutscht der halt in die Nummer rein und sagt geil ey mit AI,
Rettner jetzt die Kinder jetzt endlich mal endlich haben wir einen sinnvolle Anwendung dafür. Jetzt müssen wir es nur noch mit Bitcoin auch noch versuchen und,
mir ist schon klar, wie das einfach ein sehr ähm also für alle Beteiligten,
sehr attraktive Option erscheint, ja, also für dieses Unternehmen zu sagen, geil, da machen wir was. Das wird gesetzlich vorgeschrieben, damit äh sind wir im Markt,
Sind wir in Monopol? Für die Politikerin, geil, da haben wir äh gute Presse, da können wir uns schön fotografieren lassen, möglichst mit ein paar Kindern, die viel anhaben. So, ne? Und ähm.
Und ersten Kutscher. Nicht zu vergessen.
Und echten Kutscher. Das sind.
Ich habe hier nochmal den Netzpolitikartikel aufgemacht, das ist tatsächlich also ähm gegenüber EU Institutionen.
Tritt vorn als Charity-Organisation auf, die sich aus idealistischen Gründen gegen Kindesmissbrauch einsetzt, allerdings bracht die Organisation bei Treffen mit europäischen Behörden immer wieder seine eigens entwickelte Software zum Aufspülen von Kindesmissbrauch ins Spiel, also
Organisation, die sagt so, ah das ist ein großes Problem, äh das müssen wir angehen. Wir haben da ein Produkt.
Nicht mal ein Gesetz zu unserem Produkt machen.
Genau und deshalb also in diesem ganzen Spiel hat tatsächlich Ethik angefangen eine Domain, eine Website aufzubauen von hat sich schon äh,
Genau, mit einer Datenschutzorganisation getroffen, mit einem großen nein,
und Erklärungen von den ganzen Hintergründen und mit wem sie sich alles stattdessen getroffen hat, was schon so ein bisschen einfach zeigt. Von ähm da wäre, ne, vielleicht auch in der Vorbereitung von diesem Gesetzesentwurf wäre es schön gewesen, wenn da ähm auch von,
unserer Seite mal ein kleines bisschen zugehört worden wäre und das ist anscheinend nicht passiert und ich glaube auch, das ist ein Teil des Problems. Warum das entstanden ist, was hier entstanden ist.
Okay, aber das ist ja jetzt alles die Debatte warum ist es so gekommen? So und ich meine, das ist ja jetzt nichts Neues. Also diese Geschichte,
wir ja immer wieder in allen Varianten, bei jeder Gesetzesinitiative uns ja auch vollkommen klar
die EU da äh von solchen Unternehmen und anderen Interessengruppen
entsprechend drangsaliert wird, ist doch bitte so zu machen und hier ist unsere geile Lösung und guckt mal, da steht sogar, was weiß ich, äh
AI drauf, das fördert ihr doch sowieso grade. Das passt auch äh ganz wunderbar da in eure Gesamtstrategie. Naja, ich meine, das fressen die Leute halt einfach, weil das versteht halt einfach keiner. Es ist einfach einfach zu es ist halt einfach
komplex so und äh diese ganzen Zusammenhänge zu begreifen und dann auch noch den politischen Zusammenhang zu begreifen. Ich meine, da haben wir ja schon irgendwie ganz schön dran zu äh knabbern und dann auch noch diese ganzen technischen Implikationen ist natürlich schwierig gemacht. Ich will damit jetzt nichts
ich will dir nur diese Debatte mal so ein bisschen,
drehen vom äh oh Gott wie schrecklich ist das hin zu einem, was könnte denn jetzt einfach eine sinnvolle Strategie sein, wie man denn jetzt hier vorgeht, weil ich habe halt so den Eindruck,
dadurch, dass so viele da einfach überfahren werden mit diesen ganzen Technikkram, müsste man den Widerstand eigentlich dahingehend formulieren, dass man sagt.
Schöne Ziele habt ihr da, aber leider habt ihr euch irgendwie äh einen Weg gesucht, der nicht funktionieren wird auf der einen Seite und nebenbei auch noch alles schlimmer macht und übrigens eure Wirtschaft,
verliert dabei Geld, was ja immer super äh Argument ist, um irgendwie Leute,
Ja, also ihr ihr ruiniert eure eure Wirtschaft äh tun sie ja im Prinzip auch. Das ist ja jetzt gar nicht mal so so weit hergeholt, weil wie du schon von, ne ihr habt das ja schon richtig formuliert, dieses äh die die Auswirkung auf die,
Hoheit der eigenen technologischen Infrastruktur, von Dienstleistern, die wird ja eigentlich total angegangen und damit,
man sich quasi nur die die großen äh rein, die zwangsläufig dann alle irgendwie äh letzten Endes aus den USA kommen. So und das ist natürlich ein Argument, was glaube ich auf einer EU-Ebene dann auch erstmal angehört werden muss.
Hat bei den äh Upload-Filtern auch keine Sau interessiert, ne.
Kann ja sein, dass es irgendwie nicht nicht funktionieren wird. Ich versuche halt nur, etwas herzuleiten, wie man jetzt auch so eine Debatte macht, weil wenn wir immer nur sagen, oh, das ist aber alles total böse und Überwachungsstaat, dann kommen wir halt nicht mit weit.
Jetzt kommt Kalesi und.
Na ja, also ganz grundsätzlich, ähm wir haben da sehr lange drüber diskutiert, was man damit machen kann und grundsätzlich kann man sagen, dass dieser Gesetzesentwurf nicht nur,
gut gedacht und schlecht gemacht ist, sondern dass er einfach so schlimm ist von den Ausmaßen, die er hat, dass man grundsätzlich erst mal sagen kann, so Kinder,
Nein, also einfach nein. So, ganz grundsätzlich. Allerdings muss man sagen,
die Verbreitung von Missbrauchsdarstellungen von Kindern ist ein großes Problem und das muss man auch an dieser Stelle einfach anerkennen. Das heißt, man muss sich jetzt überlegen, wir kennen uns mit Datenschutz und Technik aus,
Wir können aber jetzt nicht sagen, was kann man tun, um weniger Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellung in den Umlauf zu bringen,
Und ich glaube, da kommen halt einfach die Expertinnen ins Spiel und das sind in diesem Fall halt Opferschutzorganisationen, aber auch Ermittlungsbehörden, die sagen können, das würde wirklich helfen und das ist in diesem Fall halt,
sehr viel Ressourcen, in Prävention zu stecken, in Schulungen, ähm in Aufklärung,
und sich zu überlegen, okay, das ist ja irgendwie ein gesellschaftliches Problem, was sich nicht einfach lösen lässt, indem wir da Technik raufschmeißen, sondern indem wir da halt gesellschaftliche Maßnahmen einleiten, um das Ganze zu verhindern.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob das ein ob ob das schon alles ist, weil ich nach wie vor,
im Hinterkopf habe, all die Untätigkeit, die wir von den polizeilichen Ermittlungsbehörden in den letzten Jahrzehnten in diesem Bereich sehen,
und aber auch andererseits die wenigen,
Ermittlungserfolge, die uns verkauft werden. Ja, also hier ähm wie hieß denn dieser dieser,
Genau, das war äh äh die eine der letzten großen äh internationalen Aktionen im Schlag gegen diese Gruppierungen und dann diese war das Münster oder sowas?
Aber irgendwo in dieser Region, da Münster Osnabrück meine ich. Ähm,
quasi eine deutsche äh Gruppe und deren Methoden waren ja Darknet Foren, Cleanet-Hosting verschlüsselt. Und es ist sehr, sehr klar nachvollziehbar, dass genau die nicht davon betroffen sind,
Und das sind die Probleme, die wir lösen wollen. Das heißt, hier wird das nochmal mehr betonen. Hier wird mit dem völlig falschen Instrument.
Auf diese,
Maßnahme geschossen. Das wiederum ist aber natürlich bei Symbolpolitik völlig egal, weil da geht's ja nur darum, dass man etwas versucht hat, dass man ein großes Ding gemacht hat und sich dafür hat feiern lassen. Zu den Erfolgen ähm äh fragt nachher niemand mehr,
und.
Ich habe hier tatsächlich den Eindruck, es gibt so einen sehr alten Witz, der aber sehr viel Wahrheit in sich trägt, wie ein Mensch abends betrunken unter einer Laterne seinen Schlüssel sucht,
gefragt wird, was suchst du denn deinen Schlüssel? Ja, wo hast du denn verloren? Ja, da hinten im dunklen Wald,
Warum suchst du ihn dann nicht im Dunkeln weit? Ja weil da ist kein Licht. Also suche ich hier unter der Laterne. Und das scheint mir so ein bisschen diese
Situation zu sein, dass sie sagen A wo können wir denn suchen? Ja bei zentralisierten Massenkommunikationsdiensten, da treffen auch viele, da merken's auch alle, ja? Also ein bisschen ähnlich wie das, was man immer.
Sind ja auch müßige Debatten, aber über die Sicherheitskontrollen am Flughafen. Die wird auch niemals jemand nochmal absenken, weil kein Mensch daran Schuld sein möchte. Ja und bei dem nächsten Mal, wenn irgendwas mit Flugzeugen passiert, dann werden sie eben erhöht.
Sie haben keinerlei Bezug zu dem, was tatsächlich
wie Flugzeuge entführt werden und unter Gewalt gebracht werden, aber sie geben allen das Gefühl, dass schon ordentlich was gemacht wird. Und,
insofern glaube ich, dass wir ähm strategisch,
oder auch taktisch diesen Gesetzentwurf nicht loswerden, ohne eine zielgerichtetere, bessere,
Maßnahme auch konkret vorzuschlagen. Zum Beispiel,
Löscht doch mal das Material, von dem ihr jetzt schon wisst, dass es im Internet ist und lasst das nicht fünf Jahre später von Spiegel und NDR machen. Nur mal so ein.
In in die Tüte gesprochen,
Ja so äh können wir nicht die die begrenzten Polizeiressourcen, die wir haben, zielgerichtet einsetzen. Noch dazu wollen wir die überfordern mit all diesen ähm Einhornbilder, die Kalesi und ich regelmäßig austauschen.
Also bringt das bringt das dem Kampf ähm bringt bringt das irgendjemanden voran oder ist das einfach ein noch hat das nicht auch noch sehr hohe Opportunitätskosten im im Bezug auf bessere Methoden,
und.
Ich ich denke, dass das sehr viel konkreter noch einmal dieses Gesamtvorhaben auch in seinem Sinn angezweifelt werden muss,
Deswegen finde ich's umso wichtiger, dass jetzt sogar Kinderschutzorganisationen wie der deutsche Kinderschutzbund sich dagegen positionieren. Also das, das ist doch wirklich das große äh das große Drama und,
Möchte dem, wie gesagt, nur hinzufügen wir müssen, glaube ich, das Ding wirklich an seiner Wurzel angreifen, nicht nur als dass es ein schlechter äh Entwurf, sondern auch der der kommt mit Kosten, ja.
Dem die bin ich nicht bereit in Kauf zu nehmen.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch das Wichtige, dass jetzt in quasi Tim, du hast ja gerade gesagt, wie geht's denn jetzt weiter? Ich glaube, das ist der ganz entscheidende Punkt, weil es gab ein ein Interview mit ähm der Innenkommissarin.
Im Spiegel, ähm wo sie auch zu allen Sachen gesagt hat, zu allen Problemen, Gegenargumenten, äh das ist nicht unser Problem, das wollten wir gar nicht. Wir wollen Kinder schützen und es ist Technologie offen äh gelöst,
Und das ist glaube ich das Wichtige, dass wir dass man das gut genug durchspielt und ich glaube, wir haben das jetzt auch schon ganz gut verstanden, aber das ganz technisch konkret wird, um zu überlegen, was würde denn da passieren und einfach gut genug, um gut genug zeigen zu können, dass das tatsächlich,
zu den ganzen, also auf der einen Seite, zu den ganzen technischen Konsequenzen führen würde, die einfach nicht tragbar sind. Also, dass dir zu zeigen, dass die Schäden auch eintreten werden und keine,
Paranoia-Fantasien sind von uns und auf der anderen Seite zu zeigen, dass die Wirkung vermutlich eben auch entsprechend gering wäre und ich glaube, wenn man das,
und das das wie gesagt das haben wir alles eigentlich gerade schon durchdiskutiert, aber wenn man das ausreichend sieht ähm dann wird dieses Gesetzesentwurf auf einmal zu einer,
vielleicht doch nicht so guten Ideen,
Ich glaube, auf der anderen Seite ähm ist es natürlich, wäre es auch total schön, wenn wir es schaffen, da ins Gespräch mit Organisationen zu kommen, die sich mit Kinderschutz und Opferschutz und so was auseinandersetzen und es vielleicht auch schaffen, ähm,
Uns mit denen auch zusammenzusetzen, zu überlegen, aber was was sollte man denn jetzt am besten stattdessen machen? Also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, der scope von dem Gesetz, ist auf die Regulierung von,
digitalen Geschäften im europäischen Markt. Das heißt, wir können da jetzt nicht mit Sozialpolitik kommen, aber natürlich könnte man trotzdem sagen.
Mit Wirtschaftspolitik, was sollte denn stattdessen am besten passieren und da gibt's die ganzen Probleme, ne, dass zum Beispiel irgendwie Journalistin rauskriegen, ah Mensch, wenn wir das selber löschen, dann ist es ja superschnell weg. Ähm also anscheinend scheint da in irgendwelche Richtung scheint noch Luft nach oben zu sein.
Und da hege ich sehr viel Hoffnung. Ich meine, äh sollte hier jemand zuhören, äh der eine oder die andere und denken, Mensch hier, ich könnte hier ein paar coole Kinderschutzorganisationen. Wir freuen uns sehr über E-Mails. Ähm.
An sich wenden, wohin sollen sie sich wenden?
Info at Chatkontrolle Punkt EU.
Minus Kontrolle.
Nein. Ach so. Wir haben alle Domains.
Wir haben alle Demenz. Okay, Punkt EU ist wichtig,
Ähm also uns hat das schon sehr gefreut, dass jetzt zum Beispiel der Kinderschutzbund gesagt hat, ey keine gute Idee, ich glaube es wäre noch viel schöner, wenn wir es schaffen würden, als,
Technikmenschen und Kinderschutzmenschen uns zusammen hinzusetzen, erstmal gemeinsam zu merken, okay, das ist keine gute Idee, wie's da jetzt steht und dann gemeinsam zu merken, okay, aber das wären Dinge, die man tatsächlich sinnvoll tun könnte, die auch allen was bringen und uns tatsächlich auch,
weiterbringen in unserem Ziel tatsächlich auch äh Kinder zu schützen,
Und äh das ist glaube ich die eine Richtung und die andere Richtung ist tatsächlich einfach äh die große Koalition daran zu erinnern, dass im Koalitionsvertrag ein äh eine Garantie quasi, eine Befürwortung ah, Entschuldigung, ja ich,
größere Koalition.
Größte Koalition aller.
Die Grökatz.
Genau, also die ähm die daran zu erinnern und das vor allem auch ähm also erfreulicherweise ist ja der ähm Verkehrsminister ähm hat heute oder gestern oder so.
Minister.
Digitalminister, sowohl als auch glaube ich beides äh hat schon verlautbart, dass er das keine gute Idee findet, ähm was in dem Gesetz entwirft.
Der mit den Fotos vom Essen, ne?
Genau, der der der der sagt, wir wir können ja gar nicht so viel scannen, weil wir viel zu viele Fotos vom Essen verschicken,
Ich glaube, was noch viel wichtiger ist zu betonen ist die Einschätzung von unseren Datenschutzbeauftragen Ulrich Kälber,
nämlich auch gesagt hat, Kinder, das geht alles gar nicht, so wie das Gesetz jetzt aussieht, ist es,
Grundgesetz Widrig und auch mit allen unseren europäischen Rechten nicht vereinbar. Mhm. So.
Ich glaube in dieser in dieser Ausgangssituation fehlt das jetzt einfach doch, dass wir die anderen äh entsprechend relevanten Stellen fragen, ey wie seht ihr das eigentlich, äh weil hoffentlich sehen die das ungefähr wie wir und ähm wir hoffen einfach, dass sich die äh große Ampel darauf äh besinnt,
dann auch irgendwann das nicht mehr zu machen und äh vielleicht einfach auf EU-Ebene da ein Veto einzulegen oder einfach stark zu sagen, ey Leute ähm das ist keine gute Idee, das müssen wir neu machen, das müssen wir neu schreiben. Äh weil wie gesagt, wir sind ja alle daran interessiert,
dass es da eine gute Regulierung gibt, die tatsächlich, also wir sind uns ja alle einig, dass es ein heeres Ziel,
Und ähm da muss was passieren, aber halt bitte ähm technisch sinnvolle Sachen, ähm die keine riesigen Kollateralschäden haben und tatsächlich zielführend sind.
Und es steht ja auch schon in deren Koalitionsvertrag.
Ja, ne, deshalb, also eigentlich müssen wir einfach nur mit ähm Engels lächeln, ähm da anklopfen und ähm ähm die einfach bitten, ähm den Koalitionsvertrag umzusetzen?
Ich habe also wir haben ja schon auch so öfter darüber gesprochen. Mich erinnert das an diese zinslose Solargeschichte, die,
die ist mehr als zehn Jahre her, ne? Also Zensur war sogar glaube ich vor Logbuch Netzpolitik. Da habe ich irgendwann mal an der Uni eine eine,
der Hausarbeit zugeschrieben.
Der Erdgeist erfunden. Der Begriff? Mhm. Zensursula ist von ihm.
Den Begriff? An dieser Stelle. Und die die Scheublohne von ist da wahrscheinlich vom Wetter oder wer hat die gemacht?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr oder wusste ich noch nie eins von beiden.
Damals noch 2009 war das. Ja, da hat Zenar von der Leyen hier mit den Stoppschildern hantiert und äh,
Gutenberg war noch irgendein Minister und ähm also der Betrüger, ne, den wir alle kennen als Betrüger,
der hat dann noch, also als das Ding losging, dann formierte sich langsam der Protest und man wurde dann eben als Menschen, die gegen dieses Kindes wohl,
äh agieren oder zum Beispiel eine, ne, irgendeine Idee von Internet gegen, also über das Wohl der Kinderstellen.
Es gab damals, den Verein gibt's sicherlich auch heute noch. Morgis, Missbrauchsopfer gegen Internetsperren und den Slogan löschen statt sperren, indem wir es geschafft haben, tatsächlich dieses äh,
Dieses politische Vorhaben teurer zu machen als seine Aufgabe,
Und ich glaube, dass wir natürlich im Moment noch an dem Punkt sind. Jetzt sind sie alle hingeprescht und haben gesagt, hier
Kinderschutz, Kinderschutz, Kinderschutz und die haben natürlich jetzt alle Angst vor der äh vor der Tagesschau Meldung äh haben sich entschieden,
nach äh Protesten der Netzgemeinde,
äh den Kinderschutz ihre Kinderschutzideen nicht weiter zu verfolgen, ne? Das ist also den Weg werden wir nicht gehen. Deswegen klar, die ähm die Kinderschutzverbände mit an Bord bringen und einen besseren Vorschlag machen.
Genau, also ich glaube, das Ziel muss sein, die Kinder tatsächlich zu schützen und das, was dieser Gesetzes- oder Richtlinienvorschlag grade macht, ist halt nicht schützen, sondern einfach nur scannen. Ähm und ich glaube, wir müssen daran arbeiten,
Zusammen uns zu überlegen, wie können wir Kinder wirklich schützen und das sicherer gestalten.
Trotzdem, dass es wichtig wäre, die Wirtschaft auch mit ins Boot zu holen, weil die auch ja, wie wir ja wissen, auch äh die Sachen nicht so gut versteht,
Wenn man sich so grad den Technologie äh Hype der letzten Jahre anschaut so und denen halt irgendwie klarzumachen, dass sie sich damit halt in in eine Technologieabhängigkeiten begeben,
Ist ja offensichtlich, dass das droht oder? Siehst du das nicht so, Crazy?
Doch also ich glaube sie begeben sich grundsätzlich in eine Technologie, ähm Abhängigkeit und ich glaube, was alle auch unterschätzen und darüber haben wir noch gar nicht gesprochen. Patrick Breyer hat das in der letzten Folge glaube ich kurz angesprochen, dass natürlich auch Firmengeheimnisse,
von diesem Scanning, betroffen sein kann.
Sehr gut. Sehr gut. Sowas lieben die.
So, also ich glaube, das ist so das Wichtigste, weil ich glaube, die meisten Unternehmen haben auch ein Interesse, dass ihre Signalchats geheim bleiben.
Ursula von der Leyen hat, glaube ich, auch ein Interesse daran, dass sie ihre Chats geheim halten,
das haben wir ja in den letzten paar Monaten gelernt ähm und ich glaube halt auch und das ist ja auch noch ein Thema. Es sind ja noch ganz viele andere Berufsgruppen davon betroffen. Also Anwälte, Journalistinnen.
Aber das sind doch alles Minderheiten. Verstehst du? Man muss die die Mehrheit muss in Ge.
Dann nehmen wir die Wirtschaftsprüfer. Die haben ein großes Interesse daran, dass sie ihre Sachen geheim bleiben.
Steuerberater, ich wäre für Steuerberater. Ja. Ganze Parlament besteht fast neuer Steuerberatern und Juristen und so weiter, also das kennen die halt.
Ich habe gerade den Tweet von Erdgeist gefunden.
Den original äh Zensola Tweet.
Kennt ihr das Märchen von Zensursela und den sieben Zwergen ist ein Laienstück.
Das war die Geburt des Begriffs, ja.
Ähm jetzt gibt es aber der Protest formiert sicher und der formiert sich sogar sehr ähm schnell. Überraschend schnell und überraschend positiv. Muss ja mal erkennen
Patrick
Breier hat das Ding jetzt seit weiß ich nicht wie viel Jahren davor gewarnt. Der hat auch schon bei der IPRC-Richtlinien ähm Einschränkungen davor gewarnt, dass das als nächstes das, was Ausnahme vom
geltenden Recht ist, dann gesetzt wird. Da haben wir alle noch gesagt, ach komm, er ist schon wieder ja. Aber dann am Ende hat er wieder Recht gehabt, ne? So, jetzt äh bestehen wir hier. Wir haben,
relativ starke ähm ja,
Bewegung dagegen. Aus der Politik, du hast schon gesagt, FDP, äh Grüne, ähm SPD-Innenministerin, müssen wir dann nochmal erklären,
Koalitionsvertrag steht ohnehin schon dagegen. Jetzt gibt's noch eine ähm Fotoaktion, die ihr letzte Woche gemacht habt,
wie die hat das war glaube ich der erste Protest auf der Straße, sind weitere angekündigt oder geplant?
Ähm genau, also wir sind gerade dabei das so ein bisschen zu organisieren. Es gibt sehr viele Menschen, die gerne demonstrieren möchten. Wir ich mache jetzt schon mal einmal kurz den Werbeblock zu Rudolf.
Es war der Aufruf dazu gerade.
Ähm genau, es wird auf der Gulaschprogrammiernacht einen Workshop geben
Die Zeit steht noch nicht fest, aber das findet ihr dann entsprechend im Programm, wo ihr euch gerne melden könnt, wenn ihr Interesse habt zu demonstrieren, wenn ihr irgendwie technisches Know-how habt, was ihr sozusagen der Kampagne spenden möchtet
Mal so sagen und ähm wir suchen ganz viele Menschen, die Lust haben, mit uns zusammen Demonstrationen überall in Deutschland zu organisieren, denn Interessierte gibt es zuhauf.
Und ihr könnt euch ansonsten auch an Demo at Tetkolle Punkt EU richten, wenn ihr nicht auf der Gulaschprogrammiernacht seid.
Und ähm uns da erzählen, was ihr euch so überlegt habt und ähm wir helfen euch dann gerne dabei, die Demos anzumelden und,
wenn ihr kreative Ideen braucht, dass Viktor als ehemaliger digitale Freiheit Papa bestimmt auch der richtige Ansprechpartner dafür.
Ehrenamtlicher Protestberater.
Wenn ihr nicht wisst, was die Gulaschspur mir macht ist, sollte man das vielleicht auch noch erwähnen. Das ist nämlich auch einer aus dem CCC Umfeld äh organisierte Veranstaltungen, die wie so viele jetzt äh lange Zeit halt nicht stattfinden können. Das ist jetzt äh die GPN
also nicht, weil sie irgendwie ausm ich glaube die waren die hatten immer allein mit mit dem Jahren, ne? Also durch Corona jetzt irgendwie in ihrer Zählweise durcheinander gebracht oder so,
auf jeden Fall findet die jetzt in Karlsruhe statt am äh ZKM vom 19. bis,
22. Mai, also vor allem am Freitag und am Samstag, was da ganz viel äh Programm, also wer da in der Region ist und Zeit hat und Lust hat, äh daran teilzunehmen, dann.
Kommen die Leute von weit her.
Da kommen die Leute von weit her, aber äh manchmal kommen ja auch die Leute von nicht so weit her. Ist ja auch egal. Also auf jeden Fall könnt ihr da hinfahren und ähm da gibt's dann ganz viele interessante Vorträge und Workshops äh,
unter anderem diesen.
Es gibt aber auch noch eine äh das darf natürlich nicht fehlen. Klick-Klick-Protest. Ja und auch der ist massiv erfolgreich. Ich sehe gerade 19.874 Unterzeichnerinnen,
für die äh Petition Chatüberwachung stoppen. Ähm,
initiiert von digitale Gesellschaft, Digitalcourage und digitale Freiheit. Wie geht's da weiter?
Da das darf ich teilen, davon darf ich glaube ich noch nicht sagen, aber ähm die sind da jetzt auch dran an dem Thema und ich glaube, es ist einfach auch mal ein sehr schönes Signal.
Zu sehen, dass da knapp über 100.000 Leute auch der Meinung waren, dass das keine gute Idee ist und auch jetzt einfach vermitteln können von gucken da drauf, wir gucken euch zu,
Und ähm genau. Es es steht ja jetzt ja aus, dass die einzelnen Bundesministerien sich dazu positionieren,
Und ich hoffe, dass das ähm vielleicht hilft ähm einfach zu wissen, da gibt es ähm einige zehntausende Menschen, äh die da drauf gucken und die da zugucken.
Und ich glaube, es ist auch noch mal wichtig zu betonen, dass unsere beste Chance, das Ding zu verhindern, ist Druck auf unsere Regierung auszuüben, weil wenn das erstmal ins Parlament geht, das Spiel kennen wir alle, dann stehen die Chancen verdammt schlecht.
Und das können unsere das kann unsere Bundesregierung, also die ähm machen,
Bevor es überhaupt in das EU-Parlament noch kommt, ja, also die können das als Kommissarinnen und Kommissare jetzt noch stoppen.
Genau, also es gibt den ähm Minister Innenrat ähm was äh das also letzten Endes, wenn so ein EU-Gesetz passiert, dann gibt's ja immer den Trilog. Das sind die drei Leute, das ist die Kommission, das ist der Ministerinnenrat und das ist das Parlament,
Und der Ministerinnenrat, das sind halt die gewählten Regierungen, die sich zusammensetzen. Ne, das sind also und da kann jedes Land, ne, nicht die Ministerinnen.
Also der Trio kommt erst ganz, ganz viel.
Genau, genau, aber ich wollte, das sind die drei, das sind die drei Institutionen, die drei äh quasi,
Drei Teile, die dann letzten Endes an so einem bis jetzt beteiligt sind und da wollte ich gerade sagen, dass der eine Teil davon, die kommen halt aus den gewählten europäischen Regierungen und die müssen sich auf was einigen. Da da kann durchaus können einzelne Leute sagen, nee, machen wir nicht.
So und deshalb hoffen wir da jetzt auf ein paar Menschen, die sich das äh entsprechend technisch angeguckt haben und gesehen haben, okay so ist es keine gute Idee.
Und dass da in diesem Rat dann ähm die Entscheidung kommt, so bitte nicht, bitte in ganz anders.
Das kann durchaus erfolgreich sein, denke ich mal, ne, weil äh an dieser Stelle, wenn man eben dann die die die nationale Karte quasi spielt, ne, das ist ja sozusagen dann kommen ja die Gemengelagen der der einzelnen Länder rein. Damals war es ja dann glaube ich auch bei Acta,
quasi so über Polen, die er da äh dem dem Druck nachgegeben haben,
kann durchaus auch noch was bringen. Es wäre natürlich auch schön, äh wenn auch das Parlament sich äh entsprechend positioniert. Wie sieht's denn da aus und in welchem Ausschuss äh wird das gemacht? Ist auch wieder dieser,
Jura-Ausschuss, ne.
Ja genau, aber also ich sage mal so grundsätzlich sieht es im Parlament schlecht aus. Das hatte ähm Patrick auch,
Letztes Mal schon angesprochen, ähm weil ähm der,
oder die Berichterstatterin, man weiß ja noch nicht, ähm welches Geschlecht die Person nun hat
auf jeden Fall von den Konservativen kommen wird, das heißt dieser Berichterstatter hat natürlich sehr viel Macht und so wie es aussieht, die die so gerade im Gespräch sind, sind das alles Berichterstatterinnen, die sehr nahe zu Kinderschutzorganisationen stehen, die das
total super finden. Ähm dementsprechend schlecht stehen da halt die Chancen.
Echten Kutschfest, Kinderschutzorganisation.
Aber die haben die Software. Dann läuft das auch.
Ein Produkt, Produkte regieren genau, ja das ist ungefähr die Situation ähm,
Ich hoffe einfach sehr, dass die entscheidenden Menschen da noch ähm technisch entsprechend gebrieft werden, um zu merken, wie,
Kompliziert wird das alles irgendwie nicht so richtig funktioniert. Wenn man ähm unbekannte Sachen äh scannen möchte auf den Geräten, dann muss man Classic High, den man dauernd nachtrainiert. Da muss man aber irgendwie, man braucht positiv Trainingsdaten, man braucht auch negativ Trainingsdaten, das heißt, man braucht im großen Umfang,
zum Trainieren nicht illegales Material.
Das hat man ja schon mal.
Ja, okay, aber das also du rauchst nicht mal fälschlich erkannt, das Material, das würde ja durch das Ausleiten erzeugen, sondern du brauchst nicht wirklich nicht also richtigerweise nicht erkanntes Material und auch davor viel, viel mehr, weil das tritt ja auch in der Realität viel viel häufiger auf.
Ah um also um deine Erkennungsmethoden an Realbedingungen ähm an.
Ja, weil sonst also das ist immer sonst das Problem, wenn du gleich viel, also wenn du nach einer super seltenen Sache suchst und,
Das ja oft auch bei äh so quasi automatisierten Detection Systemen bei Computernetzwerken ist auch das Problem, du hast irgendwie hundert Angriffsbeispiele und wenn du dann hundert,
Nichtangriffsbeispiele hast, dann äh dann hast du aber quasi eine Realität, hast du ja Millionen von gutartigen Paketen auf die paar bösartigen, dann ist das,
von vornherein schon total geweißt, das heißt du brauchst in enormen Mengen brauchst du,
legitimes Material, so wie willst du das herkriegen, du musst diese Classic updaten, du musst die immer auf Geräte neu laden. Das ist dann auch so IT Security mäßig, also gibt's dann irgendwie mein Handy, geht auf irgend so ein Server und lädt sich da dauernd eine neue Matrix runter,
und spielt die dann in in so ein orinales Netzwerk an. Also da sind irgendwie viele Sachen finde ich ein bisschen.
Aber Filter, die zu viel erkennen werden, der da als besonders streng wahrgenommen gut hier wieder mal äh natürlich, genau.
Aber als völlig unpraktikabel, weil sie einfach in in Terrabyte von äh,
völlig gutartigem Material bei den Meldestellen und irgendwann wird es auch völlig unpraktikabel, weil da einfach keine Person mehr,
Wenn wenn du fünf Stunden gutartiges Material durchklicken musst, bist du einmal böses Material gefunden hast, dann also weißt du, irgendwann wird's einfach Quatsch. Aber selbst wenn man sagt, okay, wir erkennen jetzt die,
die wir wollen das bereits bekannte Material filtern auf dem Handy,
mal nachgeguckt, also ich habe nicht besonders viel Ahnung von Fotoderna, Hashes. Wir haben jetzt die Information gefunden, dass der wohl 44 beide groß ist. Und wenn man jetzt mal rechnet einer, wenn man's mal rechnet, wir haben hier irgendwie,
eine Milliarde solcher Fotos, ähm die wir die wir in der riesigen Datenbank haben, weil wollen wir alle finden. Wir wollen ja nicht nur die,
top top 100 Fotos finden, sondern wir wollen wirklich alles davon finden. Äh wenn ich das richtig multipliziert habe, sind es zehn Gigabyte,
Auf jedem Handy müssen zehn Gigabyte liegen. Ähm,
damit damit auch jeder dieser und also jedes Handy muss erstmal ein bilden und dann durch zehn Gigabyte Daten durchfräsen und gucken ob dieser Hash einer von diesen ist,
Um zu überhaupt zu wissen, ob das Bild weißt du, also das es gibt extrem, also das ist ja immer das Problem, wenn du seltene Dinge suchst und extrem viel gutartiges Material hast, dass es einfach,
Im schlimmsten Fall verlierst du dich da drin.
Und man muss halt grundsätzlich sagen, derjenige, die die Macht über diese Datenbank hat, hat halt auch die Macht darüber, was an die Ermittlungsbehörden weitergeleitet werden muss. Oder wird.
Und eigentlich sogar in Europa Fotos verschwinden zu lassen. Es ist ja sehr plausibel, dass es so eine Datenbank geben würde, die einfach bereits bekanntes Material stoppen und ausleiten soll. Das ist ja sehr offensichtlich.
Und da muss man einfach sich auch echt überlegen, Alter, was für eine krasse Machtkonzentration.
Aber damit argumentierst du jetzt einfach nur für eine für eine zeitgemäße KI-Lösung jetzt.
Ja, also es ist, also egal, wie du's machst, ne, also aber das ist glaube.
Hat da auch so eine Organisation.
Gründe ich doch kurz aus. Aber das finde ich das Wichtige, egal wie du es machst. Ne, also es ist mein,
Und und das ist das Spannende, dass man also sobald man das technisch mal durchspielt, wie so einen Entscheidungsbaum aufmacht und sagt, ah, wir machen so, dann passiert das, wir machen's so, dann passiert das. Dann merkt man, dass es also egal, wie du's tust,
Irgendwo kommst du an Probleme, die technisch völlig unpraktikabel sind und ich glaube, das ist leider nicht passiert. Also dieser Gesetzesentwurf geschrieben wurde, dass Leute mal einfach so gesagt haben, ja, das ist zwar Technologie offen, aber,
Was für Technologien könnten sein? Wie würden die funktionieren? Wie würde das dann komplett funktionieren? Und wie würde es realistisch umgesetzt werden in der Digitalwirtschaft, in der wir in der EU leben?
Das, da finde ich, treten dann beim genaueren Hingucken treten ganz viele Probleme auf,
Und äh aufgrund dieser Probleme, dass es einfach in diesem in der Erkennung von Material auf den Handys es gibt keinen schönen Fall. Es gibt keinen Zahnfall, wo man sagt, ja easy, so machen wir das und das irgendwie akzeptabel für alle Beteiligten,
Und das ist so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung, dass das zunehmend jetzt noch die Menschen in den Entscheidungspositionen merken oder ihnen äh quasi ausreichend illustriert werden kann,
äh und damit vielleicht doch noch eine äh ein Stopp oder einfach ein besseres Gesetz wird, ne, wie gesagt, das braucht ja was, aber halt nicht das.
Es ist so frustrierend. Ja,
aber wenn du einfach mal sagst, pass mal auf, Technologie offen, ja, beschränkt doch mal die Klimaerwerbung un anderthalb Grad,
Der sitzt da auch der Markt und sagt oh das muss irgendwie ein anderer Marktbereich regeln.
Ja das wäre das sind ja eigentlich CO2-Zertifikate. Wenn du sagst, mir ist egal, was du tust, er komm ans Ziel, aber das macht dann ja auch niemand, ja.
Es ist ein äh sehr schweres Drama.
Ja genau, wir haben da glaube ich noch einiges zu tun und ähm zu reden und so in Zukunft. Ähm ich bin sehr gespannt, wie's jetzt weitergeht.
Na ja, also ich denke, wir haben ja, glaube ich, das das Feld jetzt erörtert. Wir haben als, sage ich mal, als aufgeklärte technische und äh digitale Gesellschaft, ein,
ähnlichen Angriff schon einmal ähm abgewehrt, 209 mit Ursula äh von der Leyen Zensursula-Ideen. Wir haben ähm,
da
quasi Lehren ziehen können, wie man so etwas macht, wie man einen völlig fehlgeleiteten Versuch als solchen entblößt und wie man dem entgegentritt. Aber auch gezeigt, dass oder wir haben aber auch gesehen, dass wir dafür uns eben sehr, sehr,
stark gemeinsam anstrengen müssen, dass jetzt wirklich,
ähm ein ein breiter Protest notwendig ist, an dem alle ihren zudem alle ihren Beitrag leisten.
Man muss, glaube ich, auch dazu sagen, dass es in allen anderen europäischen Ländern nicht so gut aussieht, wie wir hier das in Deutschland haben. Also das,
Politikerinnen und äh Ministerien sich schon dagegen geäußert haben, sondern dieser,
Medienaufschrei sage ich mal, den wir hatten, den gab es in den meisten europäischen Ländern nicht. Das heißt, es ist total wichtig, also wenn ihr Leute kennt,
netzpolitisch in anderen europäischen Ländern aktiv sind, dann sagt denen Bescheid, dass sie dort auch evaluieren,
auf welche auf welche Politiker in sie oder welche Regierungsposition sie einwirken können um das Ganze auch für ihr Land sozusagen zu kippen.
Es geht hier nicht mal drum, Leute irgendwie zuzutexten, sondern einfach nur technische Zusammenhänge zu erklären und zu hoffen, dass sie das auch sehen. Also ich finde, das ist einfach, es ist eigentlich wir haben sehr einfachen case hier, weil es wirklich einfach technisch nicht gut aussieht.
Müsste den Leute.
Einfach.
Ja ja.
Das kann man ja, das kann ich ja aber hier in.
Das Problem ist eigentlich schon gelöst. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo.
Äh technisch erklären, es gibt zwei sehr schöne Talks von uns, die wir in den letzten zwei Monaten gemacht haben, wo wir nochmal erklärt haben, was ist eigentlich dieses Problem mit äh diesem Kleinzeit-Scanning und so ähm was dann auch ein bisschen bildlich illustriert ist, weil ich glaube, das so im Podcast zu erklären ist ein bisschen,
abstrakt.
Stimmt, die Links organisieren wir auch noch,
Die sind allerdings entstanden vor dem Gesetzentwurf. Äh das muss man ja sagen. Die ganze Arbeit zu dem Gesetzesentwurf war so ein bisschen Spekulation, weil wir einfach mit dem gearbeitet haben, was wahrscheinlich war davor.
Ich habe euch gesagt, wir schreiben die PM am Montag und nicht am Mittwoch. So und wir gehen einfach vom Schlimmsten aus, weil kommt eher kommt.
Und Linus hatte mal wieder recht.
Das ist aber in dem Bereich nicht schwer. So, jetzt halt habt ihr mal bitte am Ende recht, dass ihr das Ding noch äh ähm umgeworfen kriegt und äh das das das wir dass wir hier noch eine eine Chance haben und damit wünsche ich euch viel Erfolg.
Viktor, vielen Dank, dass ihr zu uns gekommen seid hier in die Show. Show habe ich gesagt.
Auf unsere Schaubühne.
Show hier? Eine eine.
Ja. Ihr braucht noch ein bisschen.
Picture Show.
Ja vielen Dank, dass wir hier sein durften.
Eine Freude war das.
Ich habe mich auch gefreut, dass ich mal wieder in die Metaebene.
Ja schön, ich.
Wollen wir zu dritt eingeladen.
Noch ein bisschen ich bin noch ein bisschen verwirrt. So normalerweise sitze ich hier alleine. Ich muss mir sogar eine Hose anziehen.
Ja, die hast du auch das letzte Mal vor der Pandemie getragen.
Pandemie-Gedächtnis und Shorts,
All right. Das war's. Vielen Dank äh vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss.